Rookie move.
Perfect.
Hey,
what's up?
Hi.
Everybody fucks going on the Joe Rogan
experience podcast.
Why do I have to say it?
I don't have to say the name of it.
I can now say this podcast,
this shit.
You're listening to cost money for
bandwidth folks,
and we're sponsored by the fleshlight,
but you know that.
You know I have to go through with this
though.
Here we go.
Ready?
If you go to Joe Rogan.net
and click on the link for the flashlight
and enter in the code name Rogan,
you will get 15 percent off.
I know you're going to show that.
It's crazy.
You're right.
It is fucking crazy.
Lot of people don't even know what the
fleshlight is.
I've been realizing every time I say
flashlight,
they're like,
what is your flashlight like?
Somebody else just said it the other day
that Amy Schumer says the number one sex
toy for.
Yeah.
Oh,
she's playing stupid.
She doesn't know what a flush line is.
Get the fuck Outta here.
For people that don't know,
it's a sex toy.
It looks like a fleshlight.
I hosted the porn awards.
They were eggs at Simmons,
ladies and gentlemen.
Hi.
Here's a,
you know,
normally there's flowers in the middle
of a big party and the you get to take
the flowers home.
They had vibrators and flashlights.
So I had like,
of course I had like five buddies come
out from La to be there and we all had
one and we're running around in the
strip clubs all night,
you know,
using it like a pop it,
having fun with it and laughing about
it.
And then the next day around noon,
I call his mom like,
you fuck it.
They're like,
yeah,
you fucking.
I'm like,
yeah,
I fucked it.
We all fuck it.
It was good.
Right?
Once you have it,
you're going to find,
especially if you've got some lube
handy.
Oh you gotta have the Lube and a.
and then you got to have an exit.
You need an exit strategy.
Like if you're in a hotel,
what are you going to get?
You put it in your bag.
I carry on.
I didn't want that coming up for
security.
I didn't want it in the trash because
then the maid,
so I slipped it into the pocket of the
bathrobe in the hotel to be discovered
at a later day.
Perfect.
Did you just slip it out of its shell or
and it show.
The whole thing went in,
was right in there.
One one pack.
It's clean or not clean.
Why would I clean it?
Oh,
the dark things defined in a fucking.
You put your robot out of the shower.
Fucking you open it up.
It smells like a million dead fish.
And guess what you do then?
Well,
it good gentlemen endorsing the
flashlight.
We were also sponsored by [inaudible]
Dot Com,
o n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain,
the cognitive enhancing supplement.
Ooh,
I've got to take mine before the show.
I don't want to be stupid.
Give me something.
That new one.
Okay.
I got the new one at home.
Up to bring it in.
This is the,
the old,
the old stuff.
Um,
see I just took two powerful cognitive
much my sentences without flow better.
My mind will pick up placebo effect.
You say,
no,
I'm just that quick at breaking down
gelatin tablets.
I know how to.
My body knows how to process that shit.
We also have a bunch of other
interesting supplements for working out
for immunity,
for,
for mood.
There's serotonin boosting,
five htp supplement,
a lot of cool shit and go to [inaudible]
dot com and you can check it all out o n
n it and use the code name Brogan and
save 10 percent are right.
Dirty freaks.
Probably my friend the longest in
comedy.
Greg Fitzsimmons is here.
Hit it bitch
day.
That's a musical opening.
That's very important.
It's your real.
Greg and I started out probably within
like a week of each other,
right?
Yup.
Back in Boston,
the old Boston stitches a comedy
community,
you know,
and a dude.
We,
you and I have gone through some bucket.
We went to some crazy gigs in the
beginning.
Man,
we,
we went through together.
We went through like the darkest time
for standups.
Well the the early days.
Yeah.
We went through our personal dark.
It's the lightest time in comedy.
I see young comics today and my
heartbreaks because they got to scrounge
up stage time.
You and I,
you know,
I would say,
but less than a year into doing standup,
we were driving out and making 50 bucks
cash five,
six nights a week.
It was for me,
it was exactly one year.
I first got paid by normal a to open up
for Warren Mcdonald.
He can garden,
I don't know where it was with some bar.
I was like an apple box.
Like literally like standing on an apple
box doing comedy.
You can't fucking move.
And uh,
you know,
I had a good time and then the next time
I looked for Lindy Clark,
those are two times in a row.
I got super lucky.
Normally fall like caught me or
well you motherfucker man.
It was like all of us were like,
there was this ascension.
You would go,
you'd wait in line to get a spot on,
on comedy,
open mic night stitches,
comedy club,
George Mcdonald,
welcome to comedy.
Hell where the jokes always die.
The convenia is,
was this whole thing.
And,
and we ran out of booze.
Comedy Hell where you can fly,
fly as high as the lights on Broadway or
crash and burn and the fiery pit known
only as comedy hell and that was step
one and then you and then you would get
like a guest spot on a real show and
then you would start to get these like,
you know,
25 to $50 Mc spots where you were
driving the headliner somewhere and you
jump past all that shit because they
would send you out to feature and the
headliners couldn't follow you because
you were out of your fucking mind.
I mean you were nuts and uh,
and so they had to headline you.
So you started working like the d rooms
but headlining.
Um,
so you started to get an hour together
super fast.
Yeah.
I had to,
had to sink or swim those times when the
regular we'd make agreements to steal
each other's shit.
We're bombing.
Say,
dude,
you got my whole act.
If you're eating pick up there,
feel free to just had.
He would come back.
Do that.
Blow job jokes hills.
If you go back to peabody,
you might want to wait on.
Yeah,
he gave me.
He let the heat die out of that joke.
It was fun for us because we knew we
would.
Neither one of us should.
There was a point in time where both of
us were doing like middling gigs and we
really didn't have the time.
We really didn't have a real solid half
hour.
So sometimes you just.
When you were.
When you're a young comic and you slip
in the beginning of your set,
like the odds of you pulling stuff out
of the firearm.
Oh yeah.
I remember one time I was having a good
set and I knocked over a drink and I
didn't address it.
That was it.
The audience turned on me,
does indeed smell blood.
They knew I was scared.
They knew I was.
I was killing it there.
It's all about their uncomfort and you
denied.
I remember being on.
This was probably the cruelest thing
anybody ever did to me when I was on
stage.
It was like,
you know,
half filled room back.
It was always like the back of a Chinese
restaurant where they had a banquet room
that they just put a microphone up and
call it a comedy night and I'm up there
taking it and I'm not acknowledging that
I'm tanking it and during one of the
silences that should've had laughed,
rented after one of my jokes,
I heard this middle aged woman whispered
to her husband,
I could hear a whisper and she just
goes,
the poor bastard.
Oh,
worse than any heckle.
Jesus Christ.
It is.
No,
it would be real hard when we'd watch
each other.
You know,
you watch a friend eat dick in the
beginning too because you know how
devastating it,
you know,
there's some times where you know,
this guy is not going to pull himself
out of this and he has 15 more minutes
to go watch them.
Slosh through.
Is there a way out of it?
Do you.
What do you have to do?
Like,
do you just have to stop or do you just
material?
That's where we come in.
That's where we'd steal.
I did a great job.
I knew that they were grenades that I
had in my waistband,
Josie instead,
they would take the top off and lob it
and you're back in the game.
We would help each other
time where I was headlining where I had
no fucking business headline and there
was no way.
I barely had 40 minutes and they were
letting me headline these rooms and I
would have to stretch it all out and if
something went wrong it went wrong.
Hard hats,
there's no better motivation to creating
new material.
Then when you make those shows happen
and you just fucking have to get to
work,
like you need more weapons.
Man,
you went into weapons too quick.
You're up there dying.
Especially like you can do the hour when
it's going well.
You can take that one bit and you can
stretch it out,
add shit to it.
You're,
you're,
you're doing improvisational jazz and
that our fills out when they're not
laughing,
all of a sudden it's like concentrate.
Everything shrinks down and now what you
had as 35 minutes,
you just ripped through and 17 and now
you're scared.
So you're tense and then you got nowhere
to go except the crowd.
So you start fucking with the craft.
They don't like you now did that,
that they don't like you,
you're not making them comfortable.
So there's not like a nice flow of
energy.
And so yeah,
the early can feel it.
And the thing about Boston is,
and I think it was kind of unique to a
lot of a common other comedy cities,
is it,
it is a punchline town.
It's Bam,
Bam,
Bam.
You know,
they don't want to see something
esoteric.
They don't want to see a storyteller.
They want you to grab them and just
smack them around and then walk off
stage with your hands in the air.
Well,
there,
there were guys that were doing it that
we're so good at the best.
We came up with an error where,
you know,
I've talked about this 100 times on the
podcast and people always go,
yeah,
yeah.
We know that were really good comedians
back then.
I don't think people even understand
what a,
what a.
It was like a utopia.
Boston was like this standup comedy
utopia.
There was at one point in time there was
five clubs in a tiny little area,
seven nights a week club.
I remember there was just that one block
of warranty warranty.
It was nick's comedy stop and then there
was duck soup,
comedy connection,
and then Mike,
Mike Clark had the comedy club and the
Charles Play House above the company,
and then on the weekends you cut over to
Dick tardies,
comedy vault,
right over there,
two yards away.
It's craziness and then you get in your
car.
He drove down the stitches on common
APP.
It's like Holy Shit,
and the best part really was,
and those were for short sets.
You're doing five,
seven minutes with a big clubs.
Those were the big ones,
but then you and I would get,
and this is the thing people don't get
today,
is that we would get it for a year.
We get either you get my car,
I get in yours.
We draft providence one night for a 15,
20 minute set for free all the time.
Then we go to Hartford one night,
then we go to worcester one night,
then we go to Maine.
One night we would go anywhere.
They'd give especially a longer set,
and then you know,
we were lucky enough to come up in a
time where the word comedy in front of a
place drew a crowd.
You didn't need to have a big name.
They just were comedy crazy and we just
happened to be dropped in the middle of
it in a city that was a closed system.
They didn't have headliners come in from
out of town,
so the local,
there were four or five big local
headliners that drew and the and the
club's.
Otherwise they only booked based on do
you crush?
Are you funny?
Are you original?
So it was a meritocracy and no one ever
thought they were going to get famous
there.
What career,
if someone used the word career,
people would have looked at them
confused,
like,
what are you talking about?
All anyone wanted to do was become a big
Boston comma.
It's like the fame that you wanted was
just the being accepted amongst your
peers and having crowds coming to see
you.
That's it.
Never really expect to see you.
I think wasn't until later.
I think for us it was just,
I can't.
It's like,
you know when your first fucking a girl
and you can't believe she's letting you
fuck her after jerking off for three
straight years.
That's what it was like when I was doing
standup in Boston.
They're allowing me these stages that
I've watched since I was a teenager in
awe.
All the sudden I'm on it and they're
letting me talk.
That was it.
That's all I needed.
You know,
one of the first guys I ever saw do a
live set was tom cotter.
Tom Cod is one of the first guys.
He's a buddy from Boston is a great guy
and he was in like some sort of.
The first time I ever went on some sort
of an open mic night and,
and he was like the first guy that
everyone on stage.
I remember that.
I swear to God,
same thing.
He was like a not.
He had started maybe two years ahead of
us.
That guy,
he always used to bum me out and the
reason we used to bum me out because he
was so fucking funny to hang out with,
but he wanted to take it down a notch
and he wanted to like,
oh,
maybe,
maybe I shouldn't go so dirty.
Maybe I should.
And you wanted to go do.
That's you when you're at your best,
you're a pervert.
They twist the crazy twisted.
He is one of the most twisted dudes and
I don't want to.
I'd rather have him on.
We should have him on and do it together
because his stories,
the shit that he would do.
I,
I can't,
I can't say it on the air,
what I can say anything on the air,
but the Shit Tom cotter did,
it was one of the first guys I know that
would walk around with his balls hanging
out of his pants.
One of the first guys like no one was
doing that back when we were 20.
We were like 21 or whatever the hell we
were.
And Tom Clark is walking around with his
balls hanging out of his pants.
Jesus man,
it'd be a Christmas party and all the
comics were there and he and he would
have the hands on his hips still.
It wasn't like he was hiding.
Oh No.
And I remember at one point we were at
somebody's house and there was a dog.
It was a oliver's dog and it was a,
he had rescued one of those greyhounds.
I think Tom was putting a dill pickle up
its ass in the middle of the party.
Like we were both beyond children.
We were like,
fucking.
We were like a collection of bad kid.
It was the part of the fun of having a
guy like Tom cotter too,
is because you knew that he would like,
do something like that.
You knew he would want up things.
You knew if there was a bunch of comics
hanging around,
Carter would find a way to make
something fucked up.
I always felt like he kind of pulled
back on stage though,
you know.
Well,
he,
yeah,
he um,
in terms of practical jokes and like
guys like Kevin Knox May,
he rest in peace was one of those guys
just so fucking funny offstage and so me
cotter a Nazi or working at a place in
Maine called the laughing lobster which
started to have slow business and
suddenly burnt down in the middle of a
wet summer.
And so we're up there and we're staying.
There's a condo complex that we're
staying at,
which was pretty upscale and they got a
pool and I was all these hot fucking
chicks from Montreal to come down to
that part of Maine.
So we go,
we're going to go down to the pool and I
don't have my bathing suit.
And they're like,
fuck it,
you got boxer shorts.
She was wearing boxer shorts down.
So they head down and I walked down to
the pool.
I opened the gate and I walk in and it's
packed in there on the far end of the
pool and I make it about halfway down
the pool and they both stand up and
start screaming.
Greg,
what are you doing in your underwear?
The whole FEC rules,
red faced set me up the whole.
This is a funny thing.
There is,
it's a fucking distinction between,
you know,
a pair of shorts and boxer shorts.
It's just the thickness of the cloth at
that point.
Well,
it's the same thing of like,
you see women in bikinis on the beach
all the time.
It's fine,
but you seem an underwear.
You lose your shit.
Oh my God.
I saw,
you know Natasha Leggiero.
Yes.
She was on my podcast last week and she
asked me to do.
She does a shell at Largo,
which is like,
you know,
one of those hipster Tasha and friends.
And so,
uh,
so she brings me out.
She's about to bring me on.
She goes,
I got to just got to change outfits.
She was putting on some kind of costume
for this bit.
So she goes in the next room,
but there's mirrors everywhere and I can
see her and she gets down to a thong and
like those little things that holds you
tense up underneath.
You sat there and watched.
No,
I swear to God I was going over my notes
and it was like bing,
bing,
bing off the mirrors and I got a
complete shot and just stroke,
beautiful body taking a photo and I
stroke on it.
Can you imagine
get a lock her.
You were just grabbing your own balls.
Real weird.
Only work in the head.
A lot of twisty shit on the head.
Go overhand on it.
A lot of weird twisty shit on the head.
Yeah.
As spitting on it.
And so then so then she brings me on and
of course I have to say it in front of
the theater.
I just saw her in her underwear and I
can't really speak and so she came on my
show and I was just like,
yeah,
it's weird.
I mean if it had been a bathing suit,
it wouldn't have struck me,
but seeing somebody,
especially my favorite thing is strip
clubs do nothing for me,
but if I happen to see a woman naked
through window and an apartment,
it,
nudity doesn't get better than that.
He has to be found like Voya nudity.
Yeah.
Brian,
don't you have a same thing like were
watching the amateur porn?
I can't even do regular porn because I
know there's like five camera men in
there.
I'd rather have like,
like stolen laptop porn,
you know,
where it's or like ex boyfriend getting
revenge by sitting out photos and videos
of like his ex girlfriend and that's
what I need.
I need realistic.
Same reason why I can't watch like a TV
show at the laugh track.
I feel like it's fake,
you know,
like of course we'll have
the new,
my new favorite porn which is the
casting couch stuff.
Casting couch.
But you can't even believe that,
you know,
it's not.
That is not fake because they'll say it
to greg.
There's two moments.
Moments
I look for.
All right.
One is the hello when they come in,
I want to see if there's a cause.
Look,
I studied acting and we spent fucking
six months on answering a door in a
scene and how you react to not knowing
what's on the other side of the door,
opening it and then is it real.
I look for that and then the moment that
it goes from I'm here to do like a,
you know,
a topless photo shoot too.
He says,
I want you to suck my Dick.
It's always,
you know,
you'll make a thousand to $5,000
a day.
I'm the producer.
I make the tape,
I send it to the buyers,
you know,
it goes through me.
We want to see if you can follow
direction.
And the girls,
she's online.
She wants a job too.
Here's the money.
All the sudden the fucking morality goes
way down and then the moment always
builds to where he goes,
now I want you to suck my dick.
And you see them go fucking vacant.
You see their eyes just go like what?
And I'm telling you.
And you know what those real.
They have to have sex test before,
like std tests before they have to have
paperwork.
They have to have a location shoot,
but given by the city to have a permit
to shoot in Arizona.
Yeah.
But they still have to have tests.
Notes,
friend.
My friend is the head of,
in the Health Department of,
uh,
of California.
He,
the,
he's the head of stds and they've been
fighting,
you know,
they had a big breakthrough last week
where they have to wear condoms and in
La county now,
how could you call that a breakthrough
because it's a workplace.
People should not die of AIDS in a
workplace that's legal and it's more
realistic that they're wearing condoms.
That's what I feel that they're allowed
to take it off and still do the khaki
shots to the face.
They can freestyle.
That doesn't give you a right?
I don't think so.
Would you take aids written loads on
your face?
Um,
it depends on the,
if the guy was white or black,
there's a couple of,
there's a couple of things you've
located before the white black thing.
Yeah,
I mean that's the thing.
Put your money where your mouth is,
you know,
it seems.
I mean,
look,
I absolutely agree with testing and all
that stuff,
but I don't want to watch porn and
lester not wearing a condom.
Sorry,
I something gross.
Maybe I'm disgusting.
If they're going to do a test for me to
feel good about porn,
I want to know that her parents are no
longer living.
I don't want to know that there's a day.
I don't want to.
I don't want to know that there's a dad
out there that might see this on the
bluffs thing.
I want to know is that she's doing
because she didn't have the love of her
parents and the parents are dead.
That's the first thing I'm going to
think of.
And then it's a boner killer right
there,
son.
Yeah,
but do you want to be thinking that
while you're jerking off,
her dad's jerking off finds the clip.
Can you imagine jerking off and then
your daughter pops up?
That would be.
Is that a suicide moment?
There was a.
What was the.
Cause you've already got the erection.
It's not like you stumbled on it.
Flacid.
So you're rock hard.
You change clips as we do and then and
then it pops up your daughter naked
having sex.
You've got an erection.
You Dick's probably in your hand.
Suicide moment.
Oh No,
no.
You just stopped beating off.
Why would you do that?
That was his daughter's supposed to be
like,
Yo,
go,
listen.
I just learned some disturbing news and
as soon as I get rid of this load,
you've got to prioritize right back on
it.
You will look at,
this doesn't have to stock.
This is boulder.
What's been achieved?
A boner.
That's the cheap should be released.
So you're staying open a new window.
Minimize that one.
Come back to it just because you know
you're addicted and make the mistake.
Your daughter made the mistakes.
She'll give you digital medicine.
Interesting.
Your Dick is really more important than
your daughter.
Could you imagine if you just kept going
like,
God damn it,
I'm gonna yell at her.
Oh yeah,
I've got our Jello.
Accentuates your orgasm because now you
get mad at somebody.
What have you came and it was your best
orgasm ever.
You realize,
and it's the kind of nirvana that if you
can't get back to it,
you don't know what you're chasing the
dragon.
You got to keep chasing that dragon
dragon's your daughter.
What would you do in your daughter shot,
but you can only be shocked
by at once unless you just became a
freak and you were into watching your
daughter.
You're fucked.
That's like the seventies porn movies.
It was always like the preacher dad and
his daughter.
They used to go fucking like,
do you watch Dave's old porn at all on
showtime.
David tells you haven't seen it.
It's him watching classical porn with
the actress from it.
And I watched one of them and it was
like it was a preacher dad and he ends
up hitting on his daughter and seducing
her and then they fuck.
And that's what a lot of those movies
where they were really at a pole and
there was a lot of like rapey stuff and
repeat.
Yeah.
Rapey not full on rate.
It's interesting how times have changed
when it comes to treating women.
Like there was something,
I was watching that j Edgar Hoover show
the movie rather with Leonardo Dicaprio.
Pretty good movie.
But one of the most interesting aspects
of it as how the g man before the g man
became like the symbol that everybody
wanted to achieve and everybody wanted
to be at Gmail is young kids growing up
before it was like James Cagney playing
like these gangsters,
white hate anyone always like smushed
something in the girl's face or slapper
in the phase and like,
hey guys would be laughing.
And I was like,
yeah,
like look at all the violence that they
would do to women who have like regular
women would say something crazy and they
went to the moon.
Everybody was cool with it.
It's like they were the men that were
taking control.
The situation.
Like she needed a smack right there.
Yeah.
She had something like you were helping
her.
She was,
she had lost it.
They were helping her get back.
Like I remember something quiet man with
John Wayne.
Remember there was like his wife was a,
his brother was supposed to give him a
dowery and he didn't.
And he fucking drags through the fields
by her hair slapping her and the crap
towns cheering and you're watching.
And it's like a feel good movie and
you're like,
happy that he's finally standing up to
his wife and Christ.
Do you remember high plains
drifter when he raped the chicken barn?
John Wayne,
Clint Eastwood,
Clint Eastwood rape the Chicken Barn.
And it's like the way he treated her,
that's what guys used to do would hold a
girl down,
pull her pants down and just fucker.
If they could get away with it,
if no one was around,
that is what they would do.
It occurred to me the other day.
Are we the only species that doesn't
just.
Yeah,
I mean,
is there.
Is there sex between any other animals
that's consensual or is it all over?
Is there's one animal.
I can't remember what it is right now.
Sure.
Coursers.
We're get fucked.
I mean they
do in our study too.
They just don't want to get fucked by
all the men.
Hence the problem.
The problem is that there's judgement.
The problem is that it's not that that
people in this I don't want to fuck.
Can't find people on that side willing
to fuck.
That's not what it is.
Just there's a lot of judgment going on.
People were deciding,
now I don't like,
you know,
I don't want you.
They want some Dick.
They just don't want your Dick.
And that gets people angry.
Hence the rapey.
Wow.
So it's sociological.
It's not biological.
There's this biological and sociological
what it was purely biological.
It could all be cured with masturbation.
There's a sociological aspect to it that
women are not attracted to you and you
get angry.
You want to force yourself on them
because it's what you want.
You want them to want you to fuck them.
They don't want to fuck you.
You're gross.
Your gross to them.
So whoever we were talking about the
rapist,
you're not a rapist.
No,
no,
no.
So I think,
you know,
it's,
it's more psychological and sociological
than it even is physiological unless.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well that's not rape.
If you like holding a girl down with
your stubs and you're fucking her.
You heart.
Yeah.
You can't masturbate.
So this is the only reason you're just
like,
look,
this is,
I don't want to rape anybody,
but I got to do what I gotta do.
I gotta think you
right by a guy with no arms.
Were you really trying not to be raped?
I bet you there's a lot of dudes with
norms that could rape the fuck out of
you.
Real strong ones like farmhand guys,
just to stubs.
Just a big guy with a thick thighs.
God knows how to Pitney Down with his.
Wait,
wait,
does he put his Dick in me or they are
everything.
Whatever the arm is just loosening your
asshole up for his car because that's
how big his car.
Good,
how about that?
See,
it's a terrific movie.
You think,
well,
this guy is going to use this to.
Oh Shit.
He's gonna ruin it for the,
uh,
the penis and you're not looking back.
You don't know if it's the arm of the
Dick.
You don't even care.
You're milking a cow.
You just loving it.
Just so happy that you're not in your
mom's care anymore.
So I love this summer outreach programs.
No,
but it's a.
It is interesting though because uh,
that was the whole feminist movement was
saying that rape was a crime of power
and not a crime of biology,
but then kind of now the new thinking on
it by the postmodern feminists is that,
that,
that was bullshit that no,
it is men get horny and it is partially
what you're saying that it is about,
you know,
I've been rejected and I'm more
physically powerful so I'm going to
rape,
but that there is also like guys that
are so fucking wired for sex and
something's off and that it's,
it's about the physical act of sex as
well.
It's not purely one or the other.
I agree.
There's a broad spectrum,
a lot of reasons to rape.
Yeah.
You know,
it's,
it's just one more bullying.
One more example of people trying to get
people to do things that they don't want
to do.
There's a lot of people that like to do
that.
There's a lot of people that like to,
they like to be the boss.
They like to get people to do things
they don't want to do,
like to yell at people.
They to,
you know,
there's,
there's
a,
there's a lot of people that would love
to be a cop just so they could yell at
people,
you know,
a lot of judgment going on with human
beings,
you know?
Yeah.
And religion is um,
uh,
is it a manifestation of that are the
cause of that?
It's a manifestation I think.
I think every,
it wasn't a religion.
Somebody would make something up.
I think we're always looking,
we're,
we look so hard for someone to have the
answers that it's almost impossible for
someone with a big ego to not take
advantage.
So some crazy dude would come along with
the answers all of a sudden and then
boom,
you'd have a new religion.
So our longing,
you know,
it's like we have an amazing ability to
control our environment right now,
you know,
with,
with planes and the Internet and
physically our physical infrastructure
of our cities.
This is amazing ability,
but yet we're still trying to figure out
why the fuck we're here.
What is,
what is sex and breeding and what is the
purpose of making more people?
If I'm just going to die and everyone
else is going to die eventually,
too late,
what is our purpose here?
What,
what?
What the fuck is this really all about?
Isn't it amazing that that is really the
core.
Those three or four questions you just
asked are there is no close second to
importance in questions in life and
they're the ones you never hear talk.
And when you,
when everyone brings them up,
you belittle it.
It's like,
yeah man,
you're depressed,
you're sick.
And like that,
your breast,
I don't wouldn't want to be you man.
You had a friend who was a very nice
guy,
but he's a mormon.
And uh,
he made Romney and his wife had had
dinner with me and they were asking me
about higher powers if I believed in a
higher power.
And I said,
I don't,
I don't not believe adult like
disbelieve.
I've never been.
It's never been proven to me,
but it means it might be possible.
And the woman actually said,
I don't think I could sleep if I thought
that way.
If I had those questions not answered,
I go,
wow,
but what if there was no answer?
What if there really was no answer?
Like it's not like you couldn't get them
answered.
It's like the answer doesn't exist right
now.
Like you don't have access to it.
So everything else is just speculation.
Like at a certain point in time,
we have to accept that you have to
accept the fact that he's just too much
evidence that people are full of shit.
And these stories are terrible.
So you possibly
in most languages is interpreted as the
unknowable.
You know,
you have to,
in a sense,
it puts the onus on you.
I don't think that true spirituality
comes out of more of that idea of like
Taoism where there is a nap,
there is this force of nature that is
positive and flows.
And by humbling your ego,
you can become a part of that force
that's as close as I think if you really
boil down,
most eastern thought,
it comes down to that selflessness and
getting into a place where the power,
obviously something is making the
flowers bloom,
the sun setting at the same time,
all the shit that you can count on.
There's a cycle,
there's a cycle and it.
And it works on a,
on a,
on a micro level and a macro level at
all.
It's all consistent in a way that you
go,
all right,
there's something.
But then to say that,
you know,
what that is,
is where the bullshit starts.
You know?
And to me it always starts with like
what you're saying,
like there's a volcano.
People get scared and there's always one
guy who is so fucking cocky that he
goes,
he's always got a robe.
So he's a guy in a robe.
It's got,
I'm going to go talk to God.
He doesn't talk to you.
They'll talk to me.
And he just decides that.
And then he leaves for a little while.
He goes back and go,
here's what he said,
you guys should give me 10 percent for.
That was his first thing,
and then this other shit that's going to
play kate.
All your fears and it's going to make
you ashamed,
which will make you feel comfortable.
It's just a pimp game.
Yeah,
it's always been.
There's no answers.
That's what people need to know,
but the idea that there is no god that
there is,
there's absolutely no deity.
Absolutely.
There's no intelligence to the whole
process that I don't believe that
either.
I don't either.
I don't see any evidence that there
there isn't a very distinctive
mathematical progression to to
everything in the universe and I don't
know if you can say that there's not a
purpose for that.
I don't know if you can define if a an
intelligent form of life or
consciousness or whatever the fuck it is
created it or if it's just the ethic of
the universal things always get more
complicated,
including intelligent life in technology
and it just.
Everything will continue to get more
complicated.
Period.
That's how the universe works.
I mean that might be it.
Well,
if you look at it,
I always say,
I always say to people that are
completely,
you know,
which is the one where you don't believe
in any God at all.
Not a theist.
Agnosticism,
not.
Well.
No.
Agnostic is you don't know.
You don't believe there is a god,
you know?
I think there's not a god you haven't
been.
It hasn't been proven.
Atheism is a lack the needle denial of
any lack of a non belief in a deity and
non non theists
atheists I will say too.
Okay,
so then at that means that you're purely
darwinist evolution.
I think you can be an atheist and still
be open to something fucking crazy that
no one's ever considered.
It just hasn't been proven yet.
I don't think any atheism is absolutely
atheist rather is absolutely positive
that when they die,
the energy seizes to exist.
They do not pass into another form of
existence.
I don't think people are saying that.
Yeah.
I think what they're saying is that I
don't buy religion.
I'm not buying the God concept.
I'm not buying the man in the sky.
I'm not buying any of that.
That's what they're saying,
and that agnostics are kind of like
riding the fence on that,
but they don't want to piss people off.
So they're like,
well,
yeah,
who knows,
sort of in a belief in God the 12 step
because if you deny that there's any
kind of,
um,
uh,
there was this movie that people hated
that I actually really liked called tree
of life.
Did you see that?
What was really spacey?
Um,
it was a lot.
There was,
there were no worth 45 minutes.
And the theme of it was about,
it was grades versus nature and it,
it got me thinking a lot about,
um,
if you're going to be a pure
evolutionists and believe that science
is this thing that is,
there's an infinite possibilities,
we are one possibility and that all the
things that are happening right now are
a result of complete freaky but yet
logical science.
And I say,
well,
if that's true.
And evolution is the key,
why do we have handicap ramps?
Why do we have welfare?
Why do we have affirmative action?
It wouldn't exist.
You know,
liberals,
the ones that believe that there is no
god or that they,
they,
they downplay the God thing and they're
the ones that are constantly promoting
what I would call grace.
You know,
kindness,
kindness doesn't exist in the animal
kingdom is like what we were talking
about with rape,
you know,
that,
not raping his kindness because you
could rape but you don't.
That's great.
Something is in us,
whether it's shame sociologically,
but if you look at it more in the bigger
picture of I'm a liberal and yet I am
voting against my best interests because
there's something in me and I don't
believe in any prescribed religion,
but there's something in me in my gut
that feels like Jesus did,
you know,
so you can't have both.
You can't have evolution and completely
deny that there is some kind of a spirit
within our process as humans that's
guiding us towards something kinder than
complete survival of the fittest.
Yeah.
I think that's what the one thing that
we are,
we are an animal,
but we're also the next stage of animals
where we're aware of who we are and we
contemplate our existence and when you
contemplate your existence in you're an
intelligent life form,
you should always be seeking to improve.
If you're always seeking to improve the
thing that you look at it like what has
brought me the most positive results,
so it's kindness,
it's kindness,
friendship,
the connection with human beings on a
very positive level where you like build
up like a trust in you.
You have a warmth and friendship and you
root for each other and you share in
each other's bounty and you you build
together.
You know that we all know inherently in
our,
in our heads that kindness is like one
of the best gifts you can bestow another
human being,
whether it's giving them food when they
don't have any or helping them out or
hooking them up or doing something to
help them just or being around them and
complimenting them.
Whatever the fuck it is.
We know that inherently.
That feels great and we know it when we
know that that's the next we have to
figure out how to use our resources
together so that we can be like that all
the time.
Well,
as a,
as a person,
I see it because I know when I was
younger I would like you super fucking
competitive,
you know,
just look at standup.
I mean you and I think probably pushed
ourselves as hard as we possibly could
for about 10 years nonstop.
And uh,
and then I got to a certain age where
like now I appreciate like hanging out
with you today just felt so fucking
great.
You know,
somebody who has a shared history with
you that you know,
has similar visions on life and things
and that wasn't as important to me when
I was in my early twenties.
All I cared about was competing,
winning I gotTa,
you know,
and creatively I enjoyed it all.
But,
but I think as you get older you start
to really understand what you just said,
that the kindness and the connection is
where it's all at.
You look at all these studies,
they're doing a lot of sort of
quantifiable happiness,
you know,
studies on what brings us happiness.
It always comes down.
It's never about money.
Yeah,
I think it's always about doing what you
actually want to be doing with your life
as far as like if you have an inner
creative expression to get out and
there's a lot of people who always
wanted to be singers and they just,
for whatever reason,
never pursued it so they just sing
around their house and they always
wonder what could have been if they just
tried to be a singer.
That's one form of that that could bum
you out.
That's one form of a,
a roadblock in your life to the
depressed feeling that you didn't try.
You didn't try to reach your potential.
You didn't go after.
What is intriguing to you?
Like we all have almost like a beacon
that pulls us in a certain direction
with some people.
It's nursing,
some people.
It's construction and architecture
parent.
For some people.
For some,
for us it was stand up.
It's really simple and it's like there,
there's,
there's something,
the,
the happiness that's involved in
pursuing your,
your inherent desires is uninvolved.
I mean,
it's,
it's unappreciated.
It's under appreciated.
People think,
well,
all you have to do is find a career.
Yes.
All you have to do is find a crib,
but I guarantee you there's one out
there that you really,
really want to do.
Yeah.
Just like,
I want to be famous.
So that was going to say the key is
that,
you know,
we're in Hollywood and I see a lot of
misdirected what you're saying,
you see people that think that being
famous is going to bring them happiness,
which you certainly have more experience
with fam than I do,
but I,
you probably would say that it is
marginally helps you be happier with
giving you maybe some possibilities,
but it does not deliver you happiness.
Yeah,
it's managed madness is what it is.
You have.
You've traded the whole universe.
Brian,
how dare you keep that thing on?
Is that the turn it off?
I'm going to want to take care of it.
Don't worry.
Um,
it's,
it's a form of madness because the whole
world has changed and now everywhere you
go people will know who you are,
but you won't know who they are,
you know,
and when you start becoming famous,
it's like one out of 100,
then it becomes one out of 10 or one out
of three when you were Tom Cruise.
It's everybody,
you know,
I'm not everybody,
but it's enough so that it's weird.
It's enough so that your reality shifts
and then everywhere you go and people
have their own all.
Also,
they have predetermined perceptions of
you based on your work.
You know,
whether they can or it's something they
read that you said or somebody who met
you and you know,
oh,
he was.
Yeah,
he strikes me as kind of creepy,
is that they,
if they recognize you,
you're going to see their best side,
most likely you know,
there's the freaks,
but most likely they're going to say,
look,
I'm meeting Joe Rogan.
I'm going to tell my friends about this.
I want to have as deep of a connection
as quickly as possible as I can.
So you're getting all this energy
focused on you constantly.
I just thought when we played pool,
I mean five or six different people came
up to you and want to pictures and the
thing is,
is you're not necessarily.
Once you get over the novelty of,
hey,
people recognize me.
You're really giving.
You're just giving people something
unless you know,
unless you get a nice,
yeah,
you,
you know,
you're being nice,
which is.
But,
but for them it's like a positive
experience.
I liked it when I meet somebody,
I'm going to know if they're reduced.
You're not.
Because if they don't know me then I'm
going to see who they really are.
But if they recognize me then it's going
to be,
I'm not going to see this person.
It's true.
They may talk shit behind my back or
whatever,
but when they,
when I see them,
they're going to have a little bit of an
agenda to be nicer or try to form more
of a relationship than they would have
otherwise.
And that's confusing.
That really throws you off.
It can.
If you're not an analytical person.
That looks.
I think the most difficult person to
figure out always is our ourselves and I
think most people at least don't have
nearly enough inner dialogue where they
sit themselves down and go over all the
different shit that they're thinking and
doing and behave and most people don't
understand their own mind and if you
block shit in your life,
if you like,
I've seen it so many times with guys
that are in the closet,
guys that are in the closet that are gay
and they become like huge boozers and
they're just eating,
just blocking out this part of their
brain as they're living their life in
this tortured state.
Yeah.
You know,
I think that.
I think that's a,
that's a big issue for people.
Oh,
Kevin Meeney,
who's a dear friend of mine.
It was like a mentor for me coming up
and stand up and he came out of the
closet,
I want to say he was close to 50 with a
kid and the guy had a drinking problem.
He was overweight and then he came out
of the closet.
He's fucking trim.
He's happy.
He's got new material.
And I mean,
I just saw this load come off as skews
upon the load,
come off his shoulders and onto his
face.
Yeah.
You,
you know yourself better when you don't
have secrets.
How bullshit in your head when you don't
have problems.
What was your biggest secret that came
out in adulthood for you?
Because you changed your.
Somebody that.
Let me just preface it by saying this.
You're somebody who I think really
significantly changed in the time I've
known you and not in a bad way.
You went from being guy.
You never touched marijuana,
drinking nothing.
And you were uh,
you were hardcore,
you were confrontational.
And it in an honest way,
it's what made you a good comedian early
as you,
you took shit straight on and you didn't
back off and uh,
but you were always curious and I saw
the curious side of you kind of expand
as you got older and then I saw you
expand your mind with,
you know,
different,
different methods and,
and yet it's like you're still you,
but people don't really change usually
in life.
And it seems like something happened to
you at a certain point,
like you had an epiphany or something.
What will one thing is I got an
isolation tank and the isolation tank,
there's never been a bigger tool for me
for in terms of like personal
development than the tank.
Because the tank is you completely alone
only with your thoughts and there's no
way to distract yourself with activities
with chronic masturbation,
with fucking watching tv when he
flipping through channels late at night.
We really shouldn't be sleeping is no
way to distract yourself from your inner
most thoughts.
When you're in there,
there's nothing there but you.
You don't even get your body in there
because your body's in the warm water.
It doesn't feel the water.
After awhile,
there's so much salt.
You're floating.
So in that environment,
you're forced to take a lot of your,
your ideas head on and like,
is this a correct thought?
Did I do the right thing here?
Maybe I did,
maybe I didn't.
Let's examine this.
You know?
And then as you look at things
objectively,
it's like you're sort of forced to grow
in that environment.
The environment of the tank,
which is just another,
it's another form of a psychedelic
experience.
It's a psychedelic experience that is
natural.
You can.
It can be done while you're stone cold
sober.
He just climb on in and within.
You know,
if you've done it for awhile,
within an hour,
you're in a psychedelic state,
you're in some crazy hallucinogenic
dream state.
So what was it?
Truth over and over again.
A lot of my anger had to do with the way
I was raised A.
I hadn't seen my father since I was like
seven years old and I always thought
that that didn't fuck with me,
but then as I got older I really truly
realized it fucked with me and I didn't.
I didn't really kind of understand it
until I had a few psychobilly
experiences and kind of like looked at
the source of a lot of angst and a lot
of anger that I would have.
Like,
you know,
I would be a guy who would try to be
nice to everybody,
but I was already on a trigger.
So if something happened,
you know,
where someone did something route,
I would over escalate almost
immediately.
I would be ready to take them to fucking
full on war
immediately.
Can I tell a story?
Which one?
Well,
I don't know that we've ever talked
about this,
but we had one kind of blow out in our
life.
And it was,
you were,
I was living with your girlfriend at the
time.
Jennifer.
Jennifer from Staten Island.
Was there an ambulance?
First names.
Okay,
right.
Yeah,
I guess.
Big Hair.
Very nice growth rate.
Check.
Great check.
I'll tell the story of how this happened
because we,
uh,
we went to some club.
Okay.
I don't want to say where she worked,
but we,
we,
uh,
Greg and I were there and she came over
to talk to us and said that she had a
room for rent in her apartment and she
needed to find a roommate.
And then,
uh,
I was like,
I think greg needs a roommate.
I'm greg is looking for a room.
I was trying to get out of my friends.
We're all drunks and I quit drinking and
I needed to get the fuck out,
and so,
uh,
she walks away and greg was like,
Holy Shit,
I want to be living with her.
Oh my God,
look out.
Can Hace as I go,
dude.
She's fucking hot.
Right?
And so then a girlfriend before you
started,
before we started dating,
we had just met her.
We had just met her.
So then I called him the next day.
I go,
dude,
your new apartment is fucking awesome.
Eddie.
And he'd go,
what are you talking about?
I just,
Oh,
well,
just fuck that girl in your new
apartment.
Amazing.
You were like,
oh.
So we had like a little thing.
We're
were greg kind of liked this girl first
sort and I
fucked her and then he was living with
her and it was,
it was kind of weird and there was one
night where she had told me that you
were talking shit about me and it really
hurt my feelings because I couldn't
believe that you did it.
You,
she had her period and we were like 21
years old,
whatever the fuck it was.
You know,
you say stupid shit back then and um,
she was miserable and she would have bad
periods and you came up to her and you
confronted me with,
look,
if you're this miserable,
why don't you just fucking leave him,
you know,
like,
really,
what are you doing here?
This is what she told you.
She told me and then she told you,
Greg,
I'm on my period.
That's why I'm miserable.
And I was so upset.
I was like,
wow,
I can't believe he did that.
I mean,
she was hot,
you know,
and you're living with her.
I,
I get all that.
I get all that,
but I couldn't believe that you have
said something to her like bad about me,
you know,
because in my eyes I'm a very loyal
person and when someone's,
my friend,
they're my friend and I would never go
to a friend's girl.
But it was a very complicated situation.
You know,
it's not healthy for a heterosexual guy
to be living with a hot girl in the day
with two dead.
Uh,
but.
So anyway,
I go on this Gig and the Gig was
terrible.
It's a fucking awful gig and it was a
long drive and I did not have a good set
and I was coming back and I was with her
and you know,
she had just told me this thing that you
had did and I was so fucking mad I
couldn't believe it.
I was so fucking mad and we went and got
ice cream and um,
I went to the bathroom and I came back
and I opened my ice cream and Jennifer
was eating hers and my ice cream bar had
a bite taken out of it
and then Jerry's peace pop
and it was greg had taken a bite out of
it and so that I flipped the switch and
I threw the ice cream that your face at
about 100
miles an hour.
And uh,
I don't know what I said.
I don't remember what I said,
but I remember I went into.
I want it to danger zone.
Yeah.
Well I wanted to bring it up because we
never talked about it.
We never did.
And I want it to.
Because obviously luck.
There's always two sides.
Of course.
Three sides in this case.
Yeah.
And uh,
I think number one,
I was a brash fucking wise ass pervert,
you know,
with a lot of energy back then.
And so first point I would say is that
with Jennifer,
if I said I can't believe it and live
with her,
I think it was probably more of a comic
premise than like a real attraction on
any level.
I think it was like,
yeah,
she was hot but I wouldn't be moving in
with a chick to try to get laid with
her.
Probably more like that.
I'm not saying that it was a residual
feeling with you that like I had said
that and it was maybe on your mind that
I'm living with her and you know,
that's a little bit.
I'm pretty open minded dude.
She was living with another guy,
the gay guy and I would go out with them
all the time while he was gay.
Don't give it up.
Same Damn it.
So cut the whole thing.
And the other thing is if
I,
and if I,
it's possible I might have said that
thing about.
Wait,
let me just say my side of it.
It's possible.
Who knows?
I might have said something about you,
you know,
and again,
I was a fucking loud mouth.
I sat and talked a lot of shit.
I think that in my heart you and I are
good friends.
We had come up and done a lot of shit
together,
gone through a lot,
support each other a lot.
And I think if I'd said something,
it's again,
I have no fucking idea.
I don't remember.
You know,
it's so long ago.
The memories aren't real anyway.
They're not.
No
brought it up in this,
in this arena because I feel like I
don't know if there's humor in it,
but I think that there's a real moment
in it where,
you know,
we were,
I think it fucked me up too because
first of all seeing you get that angry
was like,
you know,
scary shit.
And it was the irony of you hitting me
with the Ben and Jerry's piece.
Pop was also not completely lost on me
and I,
and I felt
like,
you know,
and sadly that was right at a time when
you were moving to New York,
you started going down and working in
danger fields and all that shit.
So it became kind of convenient debt.
We just didn't see each other as much.
We will fucking write together every day
we drive to gigs and then all of a
sudden this kind of blow out happened
and uh,
and you just happened to be moving.
And so we spent a few years of just not
being in each other's spheres at all.
And then it was water under the bridge
and we started to,
you know,
hang out and all that stuff.
But I always wanting to talk to you
about it because I felt like whatever
your takeaway was from that experience
that,
you know,
it was,
if I did say something,
it wasn't from my heart and that I think
it was a loaded situation.
It was a load of situation and there was
a few other things that,
wait a minute,
a few other things that we're leaning
into that confrontation that,
you know,
it wasn't anything bad that you did.
It was sort of an attitude that you had
taken with me.
I don't know.
It was weird.
There was a,
there was a resentment thing.
I'm pretty,
uh,
pretty sensitive to it.
Everything.
A lot of it had to do with living with a
girl.
Well,
you and I grew in different directions.
Comics,
you,
you were going hardcore.
You were hanging out with another
Michael and you were real Kennison guy
and I was starting to move a little bit
more towards
clean.
Clever.
Yeah.
I was going through a
cleaning clever stage and you gave me a
really hard time about it.
You could call me a pussy and you got to
fucking be real up there.
It was intimidating because it was like,
well,
I'm not worried telling me how to do my
act,
but you will get really down.
You would get pissed at me because I
loved you.
I just want,
didn't want to see you back off you were
you when you were at your best,
Greg fitzsimmons would have the sets and
you would,
uh,
you would have a bunch of really well
crafted jokes,
you had a bunch of good things and you
have one thing where you just went over
the fucking edge completely and the
comics would be howling and I always
knew I was like,
if he can harness that,
if he can figure out how to do,
I mean you have a sick fucking sense of
humor.
So when I would see a pull back,
like to do a letterman or pulled back to
do any of this stuff,
I'm like,
the only reason that exists is there's
someone trying to
sell Toyota trucks or tie.
The only reason why censored TV exists.
So this idea that it became clean and
clever.
I'm like,
what is clever about cutting out the
most fun aspects of life and
homogenizing it for so that four year
olds can watch it really?
Is that.
What's clever?
That's clever.
That's not real comedy.
And in my head back then I was watching
you and saying,
well yeah,
you're just going up there and you're
just fucking throwing shit and common
their faces and your healing and your
fucking prancing the stage and a stock
and you're fucking guys your hand over
the money.
And I was just like,
you know,
he's killing it.
But like that's like I was coming out of
college as an English major and I want
it to.
Right.
You don't have gone into writing.
So to me it was just a different choice.
And it was one that you didn't respect.
No,
it's not that.
I know.
You just said it.
You didn't really know I want.
I know.
It's not that I didn't respect the
writing.
discipline of it.
I know it's more difficult.
It's more difficult path.
It was that with you.
I always knew you had a sick fucking
sense of humor.
So I was like,
oh,
it's like going back to Tom,
don't pull,
don't pull away from that.
Are you crazy?
That's like what makes you unique?
That's what makes us Howell in the back
of the room.
I mean we're not laughing because we
like you and it's not funny.
It's like you would say some really dark
fucked up shit and they need bill eric
and never use that,
but they won't use me now.
But Boston comedy will book me on the
road because of the,
you know,
they will.
I think that there was a part of me that
I think in baseball terms you were
always the guy that was the grand slam
swinger and I was the guy that just
wanted to get a lot of doubles and
singles and so in a sense I think
everybody,
my father used to say,
everybody ends up where they're really
comfortable,
you know,
and in a sense for you,
like you talked about going on stage
when you didn't have the material,
but doing an hour like balls out,
I'm fucking do.
That wasn't me.
That would've been my worst fucking
nightmare.
To me it was like I wanted to make a
living doing this.
I wanted to write.
I want it to go on Letterman.
That was like things I wanted that,
that we're in this strategy,
not that I like thought about it,
but it was just natural where I was
going and for you it was like,
you want it to fucking explode,
you know,
you want it to be innocent and that was
just a different fucking strategy,
different game plan than I had and I
think that was a big part of it too.
That was a lot of the tension underneath
the fight that happened.
I,
yeah,
I really,
really well I did.
I resented that I was feeling like you
were not approving of what I was doing
and you're putting pressure on me not to
do it.
That's hilarious because I always felt
like that it was always the opposite
with people,
that the people that we're dirty,
we're especially back then in Boston,
they were the ones who were pressured,
pressured to clean it up.
Oliver,
Keith Lee,
that's all he ever used to tell me.
You got to clean it up.
You've got to clean it up.
You said 10 bucks and 10 in 10 minutes.
Clean it up.
Yeah.
It was always like,
oh,
like I'm taking some sort of a shortcut
by doing things and I'm actually
interested in talking about,
so you saying that I think that I look
down on you for for cleaning your act up
or trying to go the professional route
and it wasn't that,
it was never that.
It was that I didn't want you to
stop doing the other staff because the
darkest shit was the shit that would
make me laugh the most.
And then when you look,
I can't do that,
but anymore I'm like,
you're crazy.
That fucking bits.
Awesome.
I know in some of the bits I look back,
I can't.
I'm one of those people I cannot watch
myself.
I've early tapes.
I look at these clever fucking cute
jokes I was doing.
I just remembered something he did that
was fucking brilliant.
This was back in the day where there was
like,
maybe it's somebody had heard the jerky
boys,
like maybe like one one,
one of the cds were out and like they
were really kind of funny,
recorded phone calls where they would
fuck with people.
Greg did one where he called in a car
rental place and you didn't win this
extreme,
extreme Boston accent for years,
for years after that go.
It sounded fine.
The whole on fire you had that.
You were doing a lot of dark.
Well,
the thing is when you talk about the
Boston comedy community,
we really did have our own little pot.
It was like me.
You caught her a Mike Mcdonald,
McCarthy McCarthy.
It was really only a half a dozen of us
that and I felt like an outcast.
I didn't,
you know,
there was Dave Cross and and Marin and
all those guys that were doing like that
sketch esoteric stuff in Cambridge.
Then you had like we talked about the
big headliners that were,
you know,
they had their own.
They were,
they were drinking
in.
They were and looked at it in a
different way.
You know,
those guys who were looked at as being
clever with good material.
And then there was guys who were like
Knox who will,
like a lot of people would like,
they would look down on them.
They looked down on that material.
That's silly party guy,
sort of estate
collar much more and yet we didn't fit
nicely into any of the categories and so
I think we were left in like it was a
little bit of the misfit Toys Syndrome,
you know,
I,
I kind of felt like,
um,
you know,
it wasn't about being clean or dirty,
it was just more about like resenting
people that were fake and like seeing
people that were again looking like they
wanted careers and non backstabbers and
all that shit.
And I felt like there was like a safety
among the five or six guys we hung out
with that we were like real people and
that we were doing ballsy comedy and
that we were the hungriest ones out
there.
I mean you went to an open mic night for
those couple years.
Ours with the first fucking names on the
list and we were standing there like
panthers waiting to see if we were going
to get on.
Yeah.
We're not boasting.
We really did drive to Rhode Island all
the time to do free sets all the time.
Constantly trying to the point where
they would hold it over our head guy.
Now maybe you might not even built yet
alone.
Remember that dude,
Charlie,
it was kinda creepy about that.
Like hold it over your head and let her
know tonight.
Yeah.
He was this very flamboyant guy.
He does cabaret now and.
Oh boy.
Did he liked checking you out and making
you kiss up to them?
Charlie?
Um,
should I say?
Yeah,
well I do that mainly when the bad guy
now just,
he shouldn't have had that power,
you know?
And there was just a that,
that whole little comedy scene in Rhode
Island was very small.
There wasn't.
Remember that one fucking really funny
was Eddie.
He was your favorite.
Eddie uh,
damaged.
Um,
Eddie tell the story.
Well which one
when you first dell his favorite joke
about the,
uh,
the,
the um,
disposable douche commercial at the
mother and the daughter.
Oh yeah.
But a lot of people.
Galvin,
Eddie Galvin,
yes.
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah.
Yeah.
What was it though?
Because this disposable douche
commercial,
it's a mother and the daughter walking
down the beach together and the daughter
says to the mother,
stinks,
but the cats have been following me
and the Grad would plumping go nuts and
then he ends up going to jail.
We either got a death with a stick,
but the tree limb.
Yeah.
I don't know what happened.
I don't know what it was over.
He was the second guy to go to jail.
There was another guy named Ed,
the machine regime.
Who Was it?
Who was working also as a used car
salesman who set the odometers back cars
and did about five or six years.
Yeah,
I remember that.
I remember when he got out.
I remember when he got out,
he got out and he started wearing like a
gangster suit and a hat stage at the
machine regime.
Yeah.
He was a good like functional comment,
functional comic.
He knew how to get the laughs and then
there's the other Rhode Island comic
who'd put a clam suit on and then he
would close out with a bit where you
seeing muddy waters.
I'm a man,
but it's.
I'm a clam,
I forgotten the crab with those their
shit and then you're on next.
That was,
it was always about who you had to
follow in Boston because you'd have
outrageous shit like that happen and the
crowds in some towns were so dumb.
I mean Rhode Island,
they were all dumped and you'd have to
go on after that and,
and it's like they just fed the fucking
mongrels some red meat and now you're
going up and it's like,
whoa.
You were there with me on one of the
Times.
Were Hicks performed in Boston and we
saw him clear the room clear the were,
it was you and me and mccarthy and a
couple other guys.
Maybe it was a todd parker.
He might've been with us.
It's like a Sunday night and,
and Hicks went up there and he went on
after Larry.
Dr Larry.
Uh,
yeah,
no,
La Comic on a Harley and Mary Norton.
Norton Norton.
So Larry Norton goes up and he's doing
like cartoon characters.
If they got high,
this would be bugs.
Plenty of.
Got a really simple shit.
Cops and donuts,
you know,
like,
like really like softballs,
he's lobbing a match,
right?
Kill it.
He's killing and Hicks goes on and just
just each deck right away from the
moment.
His very first joke,
he's like patient with his,
you know,
what he's going to say and thinking
about things.
It just goes and some weird points and
the crunches gets up and fucking chunks
and so maybe 45 minutes into a set,
40,
40 minutes and knows what he's doing
this bit where he's,
he's playing John Davidson and John
Davidson gets fucked by Satan.
John Davidson used to be the host of
that's incredible.
And John Davidson is getting fucked by
Satan and he swells up in the off season
and shits out.
Geraldo Rivera becomes pregnant with the
demon seed and it becomes Geraldo Rivera
and he shits it out and he's like on the
toilet,
shitting out Geraldo Rivera.
And he's grunting for like fucking two
solid minutes,
maybe more like literally no words,
no words,
no words.
And then he looks up in the middle of
people just getting them in trouble.
He goes,
Yup.
That's usually clears the room,
goes right back to it and it was just
you and I and a couple other guys in the
back of the room howling laughing.
Maybe 50 slash 50 people stayed and
wooded next seat,
like the seat 300 maybe.
Yeah,
about that 200 plus people got up and
left and we were howling and I just
remember we sat,
I think another time we went to see him,
it was at the faneuil hall comedy
connection and we actually got to sit in
the green room for,
you know,
10,
15 minutes,
nothing but small talk.
But the fact that fucking sat in a room
with that guy,
got to see him perform a couple times.
It really is like a,
you know,
comedy history.
He was,
you know,
a lot of.
He gets a little shit from a lot of
people because a lot of his ideas are so
commonplace today that people go,
oh well he wasn't even doing comedy.
Like,
you know,
like what are some of the stuff isn't
even funny,
but what they don't understand is that
like every fucking comedian your stuff
gets dated in time,
you know,
it just,
it does,
it loses,
it gets replicated again.
And again.
Well Lenny Bruce,
a lot of,
you know,
even Hicks's premises were like really
similar to Lenny Bruce's premises.
One of the Lenny Bruce premises was that
people don't,
he doesn't understand the cross,
you know,
years from now when people going to be
running around with electric chairs
around their necks.
And then Hicks had one about,
you know,
it's like going up to Jackie Onassis
with a rifle pendant.
Just thinking of John Jogging.
Yeah.
Know what I mean,
there's similarities.
But what would hicks did was completely
changed the way people do comedy.
Like all of a sudden people to have
comedy that would make you like make a
point.
And like it would be parts of it that
would be funny,
but there'll be parts of it that would
set up the funny by pointing out how
fucking preposterous so much of this
shit is.
Yeah.
And it's like it was a different ride.
It wasn't that Don Gavin punchline every
fucking three seconds,
Bang,
Bang.
It was a different ride.
Well,
I think the turning point was really a
declared.
This distinction with him was that he
didn't care.
That's what it came down to,
was comedy.
That to its core did it was expressing
itself without any regard to their
section it was going to get from the
audience and he figured out quite early
that that was the way to find your real
audience.
Only performed their stuff and
eventually everybody else leaves Jesus,
this is terrible.
And then your people come long.
Carlin did that too.
In a way.
Shura be guests,
but he would become famous
already.
Karlyn had become famous as sort of a
clean and squeaky.
But then he became,
I think a guy who was by the end to a
fault more about his core beliefs and
ended in his message.
I think he went so far with it,
but in the sweet spot,
I think he was on the same level as
Hicks in terms of like taking on,
you know,
religion.
Forget Bill Hicks was doing it in Texas,
you know,
he was taken on Christianity in the
Bible belt in the eighties and he was
doing it in a way that like,
it wasn't that setup punchline and he
started like that.
I mean,
I watched this documentary,
he had like really cornet.
He was the guy,
if you want to get to the place where
Bill Hicks is,
you got to be.
And Carlin,
you have to learn the rules to break
them.
And they did.
They were very high functioning,
clean,
you know,
monologue comics.
And then they took that and they,
they made it dangerous by taking on real
ideas and at the time that's what
everybody is doing.
And what he had done was running to
Kennison.
And then Kennison completely changed his
act.
And in fact,
when I first saw Hicks Hicks was doing a
lot of Kennison in his act,
much like you,
you know,
you realize when there was a few guys
that would do,
um,
a bunch of guards that will do Boston
guys that would sound just like Knox.
Oh yeah.
And they would do it just because there
was confidence in sounding like a really
funny guy,
like a guy that you respect.
There's a confidence in it.
And when I first saw Hicks,
it was years before that set,
maybe a year,
year and a half before that said,
the first time I saw him he was doing
like a sort of a bit of a kinison and
you're like,
he wouldn't even make like we do like
the walking dead.
He would roll his eyes and he said,
make the same noises that Kennison
would.
Megan.
I'm like,
wow.
Like,
that's really kind of close.
It doesn't,
you know,
we've seen kinison.
Bobcat probably had a touch of that.
I think.
Uh,
you know,
Marin had a touch of Hicks when he was
coming up.
He had a touch of the mannerisms.
He would replicate math.
That's what I mean.
The matter is,
you see that with a tail now.
Lotta young towels out there.
Yes.
A lot of young guys stand hopes.
Yup.
You're right.
A lot of.
So yeah,
there was one time I was listening to
this fucking guy on,
on a raw radio and I couldn't believe
it.
I was like,
this is a fucking stand hope clone.
confused,
like maybe standing up at a cold or on.
Sorry.
No,
it's a different guy.
Does he sound like staying home?
No,
no.
Funny.
Or You just,
it's your opposite.
That's your olive garden because he was
on.
Sorry.
So going back to the original topic,
our fight.
Glad it's over.
I'm glad.
So I think that we're both uh,
well we kind of abandoned it.
Know what I mean?
I didn't really,
we didn't speak that much after that for
awhile,
but it never came up again.
It wasn't like it needed to be
discussed,
but I'm glad we did it.
Yeah,
I wanted to just clear it out,
clear it out because a,
I was thinking today too,
I think I was telling you earlier,
I changed my whole viewpoint on,
on gun control two weeks ago and did a
lot of research and,
and,
and it's like,
I think that there's a,
there's two kinds of people.
There's people that will call people
when I make a mistake,
apologize,
I tell I want to talk about shit.
If it's,
if it's under the and I
want to,
I want the right to change my mind
later,
you know,
and I think that that's,
that's the way I choose to go through
life.
I never want to fucking.
And it's probably my family growing up,
Irish Catholic.
I wrote this fucking book.
That was all the real shit from this was
like,
uh,
I didn't,
I didn't think for one second when I
wrote this book,
my mom's going to read this,
my aunt's going to read this.
I just fucking wrote my book and it's
like,
you know,
it was uh,
it was tough,
man.
I almost had a fucking nervous breakdown
doing it.
Uh,
but that was like the point in my life
where I think I went,
you know,
I'm,
I'm no longer going to do anything
that's pandering.
I'm only going to be honest.
I'm only going to confront things in my
life because I can't go back.
You know,
I want to start my life in a sense over
again and leave everything behind so I
don't want anything fucking connecting
me to shit that I feel bad about from
the past.
So I just like spit it all out,
put it out there and now it's done.
And now this has done not the podcast.
Please not the podcast.
I haven't gotten
my plugs in yet.
No,
there's no plugs.
We can keep going.
I'm glad.
I'm glad we got it out of the way to go.
Uh,
you know,
we,
we actually worked together on the
mantra as well,
you know,
it came up,
cause I had an issue,
you know,
and then they said,
what about Greg Fitzsimmons?
And I was like,
you just fucking talented,
you know,
for sure.
Hiram.
I was shocked,
really shocked.
I was like,
it reaffirmed what I just said that
you're like that.
Also like,
you know,
I'm not gonna guys get over Shit.
Well,
you know,
bottom line is there's no way I could
hold a grudge that long a and B,
you're fucking talented.
And it was like,
it was a,
it was like,
it wasn't even a thing.
It wasn't like,
like,
man should we work with.
It was like,
of course we should work with them.
You're a funny guy.
You know,
you had a funny shit that I didn't even
think would,
could be funny.
And became funny that the uh,
the dead Ted Williams sketch that was
fucking brilliant.
Ted Williams frozen Ted Williams was
awesome.
That was turned out to be one of my
favorite sketches because I don't give a
fuck about baseball.
So I was like,
no,
I don't,
I don't understand it.
But it was great.
Yeah,
it was,
it was tough.
You were fucking,
you were working.
That was non stop.
It was a disaster.
You would show up like,
you know,
at night when you were done taping all
day and then write all night and then go
back out.
It was a disaster.
I was working way too much.
I was doing fear factor and the mantra
at the same time.
And we had all the sudden,
like the,
they had completely changed how they
were approaching it.
Like Doug and I got completely
hoodwinked.
We thought that it was going to be like,
they literally told me like,
you know,
have nudity,
we'll blur it out.
Swear,
we'll beep it out.
You can go wild.
If we get sued,
it would be a good thing.
We can use the publicity.
And I'm like,
let's get fucking crazy.
I'm like,
let's do it.
Um,
you know,
Stan hopes and I'm in,
come on,
let's go.
We're going to fucking change the
manager.
And then once we started,
that doesn't sound like the man show.
That's not the man show.
That is not how the man show used to be.
Like they had never had power.
I found out that Jimmy and Adam had
given up the power so that they can have
creative control.
They didn't,
they,
they're like,
look,
you could,
you could own this fucking piece of
shit.
Just don't just leave us alone,
you know,
just let us come up with their own
style.
Like they had.
They had had to give it up to get
creative control.
That's why it was good because once you
get in there and you remember what it
was like,
it was nuts.
It was the beginning of comedy central
becoming a really uncreative place to
develop and do things and it was,
you know,
it was the studio and the network it.
We're probably six.
All women,
all women.
Every note on the man show was coming
from women,
which isn't to say they weren't
talented,
are funny.
It just always struck me of like,
do these people really have the voice of
the show?
They don't.
I don't think women were watching the
man show.
One of the big things was Joey Diaz.
I wanted Joey Diaz naked at the
beginning of every show.
That was a mistake.
He would kick open the door,
go,
let's get this party.
Everybody would go crazy.
Zoe was comedy central executive crying.
Why you tell me?
Why is that funny?
That's not going to be funny with this
is not what we wanted to do with the
show.
She was literally in tears.
I'm like,
first of all,
there's no crying in comedy period.
Right?
There's,
that's fucking ridiculous.
At second of all,
you know,
I know I understood her point of view.
She's an intelligent woman.
It's offensive to her.
To her it's not funny.
She wants well scripted.
We know well crafted,
you know,
really clever pieces and bits that
appeal to understand this.
How ever win a fucking 350 pound fat
Cuban guy with a baseball hat and
timberlands comes running out as balls
are like grapefruit and old ladies.
Pantyhose and his Dick is big and it's
flapping around on his giant belly.
You cannot not laugh when he's going,
let's get this party started.
So we made a deal.
We'll do it your way and then we'll do
it my way.
So we did it her way.
Nice big thing,
big cheer.
Everybody gets crazy.
We started the show.
Okay,
take two.
We do it.
The second time show ideas comes out
naked in the police,
falls apart.
People are,
they're giving them standing ovations
and cheering and Joey's dancing and then
he brings us out and it was perfect.
Yeah.
And then that was the beginning of many,
many problems that we had.
It just,
I should have never tried.
I shouldn't never tried to do a show at
the same time as doing another show and
on top of that I should have never tried
to do someone else's show.
Well,
that's.
Yeah,
I mean,
look,
that's a fucking tough.
When you look at the fact that the
office turned out a different office
that is now as good as the original is a
fucking miracle.
Amazing.
Luke doesn't happen.
Not talented people.
Obviously they.
They figured it out there and those same
people could have taken a different
premise starting from scratch and been
where they are today,
shaking a,
taking a show that already existed.
You're not getting any boost data that
you're.
All you're doing is fighting off the old
image and trying to recreate the new
one,
so why not just start with the new one?
I think
America was so distant.
It was a distant memory in people's
minds.
There was this English office,
like there's a giant chunk of the
population that had no idea and the
people that were fans of the office
tuned in out of curiosity and the other
people tuned in after.
Yeah,
I've heard it's really good.
I heard it's really good,
you know,
like it was not known enough so like
slipped in.
But you were doing it on the same
channel?
Yeah,
with the same name and the same set.
Yeah.
You see,
and the thing is,
it's like that was truly.
I mean Adam and Jimmy had worked
together in radio.
They had a fucking chemistry and a
fluidity.
You and doug are both Alpha males who do
stand up alone and then all of a sudden
it was like,
should we sit on stools?
Should we stand up?
And I was always just like,
no,
Joe should go out and tear it up for
five minutes.
Then Doug should.
Then they should throw the clips that
they are both in but the two to you
standing on stage together,
which was weird.
Yeah,
it didn't work.
You know,
we should've done.
We should've,
we should've looked like after the first
time didn't work.
We should've said,
listen,
we should just read.
The only way we could ever do this
correctly is if we just stopped calling
it the man show and it becomes a new
thing because you just can't say,
that's not me.
Like they would be like,
that's not man show.
That's not man show.
Especially remember when Janet Jackson's
nipple thing happened,
we got fucked.
We lost like half of our monologues.
We lost a bunch of bits we couldn't do
now.
Oh,
because everything tightened up.
Everything.
Yeah.
Realize that,
that stupid stunt had a big impact
because the dummies that run these
networks,
they just don't want to lose their jobs.
So they'd go into panic mode.
We've got to react to this trend of
trucks.
You give me anything you have that could
cause us trouble because now the
microscope of the media is going to be,
you know,
people are going to be like peering into
every single show looking for anything
that's possibly offensive while this
whole wave of indignation washes through
the nation because someone saw a woman's
tit during the dinner hour
did,
uh,
um,
one of the sketches that I wrote was
called a ill suitors and it was like a
dating service for men that didn't want
longterm relationships,
pair it up with women that had terminal
illnesses and one of the scenes.
And it was all like,
you know,
Doug had this funny idea of like she's
in a wheelchair on the beach trying to
wheel through the sand and he's running
in slow motion towards her and it,
it,
it ends with like,
it was supposed to end with him.
I'm making out with this woman in bed
with his hand up her shirt.
And then it goes to him giving mouth to
mouth and pushing it.
And then they just,
they killed that.
It was like we had no ending.
And so we had all these funny ideas of
like,
you know,
you could,
you could order like a three day weekend
special of bird flu,
you know,
you have different diseases that matched
up with how long you want it to stay in
the relationship.
It was weird too because Giana sorta
took over the show and he became like
the voice of it and you know,
he was the amount mayonnaise,
you know,
he's a fucking executive producer who's
got to listen to the networks.
We never tried to do somebody else's
show.
Now.
A lot of funny writers to Brian Posts
saying,
Ray James,
Chris Mcguire,
it's funny shit to let me shoot came out
of it.
Frank Sebastiano was awesome.
I think he's the best writer in town,
period.
Great.
Jesus.
It was good writers.
Yeah.
Too Bad.
Have Fun.
You know,
you and doug still a keep in touch.
Yeah.
One of the things that came out of that
was A.
Doug and I were doing mushrooms the day
the war broke out.
We w we sat around the student's house
in the desert.
We did mushrooms and that day it was
like,
right when we were planning to do,
uh,
the man show,
the war broke out and they were,
they were showing that there was going
to be beginning war coverage at 5:00
PM and stanhope goes,
Holy Shit,
there's a kickoff and were tripping
balls in the desert like where you could
barely focus on the TV because it's
become a,
a soup of pixels,
you know,
it's not really the TV anymore.
Wow.
Yeah.
Interesting Times.
That was a good time,
but I definitely shouldn't have done it.
I'm glad I did it,
but I shouldn't have done it.
Yeah.
Well who knew?
I mean,
I,
I've done a,
I've been on a couple of pilots at where
people end shows actually tv shows where
people were double dipping,
you know,
I wrote on Wanda Sykes Shell last year
and she was doing the adventures of old
Christine and then coming over and
trying to do her show on Fox at night
and we never saw her while she's so
fucking talented and like what an
opportunity to have a black woman while
Obama is president.
And you know,
all these,
you know,
and you had Sarah Palin running for us.
All the sudden the floodgates were open
and show was it,
it was just a straight up monologue,
remote piece,
round table talk,
shelf topical.
Because she's so talented,
she's great,
but people don't give themselves enough
enough time to do things.
Right.
And if your name is on it,
you got to fucking drop.
Either don't do it or drop everything
and say like a tell again going back to
this show,
what you got to see?
Dave's all porn.
That guy gave up so much fucking work.
He invested so much of his own money.
Tons of it into this show because his
name was and it's picked up and is
roadwork is up and is merchant and you
know,
it's like this is you,
this you're fucking brand.
Yeah.
Hmm.
So you blew it man.
He really blew me.
How did that happen?
How did it come to that?
Well,
you think you would want to do a show
like that again?
Like a weekly scat?
No,
no,
no.
I like this.
This is really what it should have been
doing all along.
This is the most fun podcast.
It's just this is,
you know,
I mean,
what,
what do you,
what are you providing?
You know,
when you have an hour television show,
you're supposed to be providing
entertainment.
You're supposed to be providing some
sort of a release.
I think I'm better at entertainment
doing this than I am at all that other
stuff.
Yeah.
I think writing.
I can write.
I know how to make sketches.
I can make funny stuff.
I absolutely can.
It's fun.
I enjoy doing it.
I enjoy this more and between this and
stand up comedy.
Those are like my two favorite things.
Like the only reason why I ever did
acting is because they gave me money to
do acting.
Yeah.
I mean I had to do acting because I did
MTV and I got a development team and all
of a sudden I'm doing a pilot for a
sitcom,
but I never really wanted to be an
actor.
So it's not that appealing to me.
And then when you hang out with them,
you realize,
well,
there were fucking Weirdos,
weird fucking pretentious self absorbed.
Strange fucking people,
man.
They're odd.
Nobody's saying a truthful thing all
day.
Oh,
everyone's trying to be.
This was the same person.
The person that like is everyone that
everyone accepts.
You know the person that you know,
everyone.
Everyone's liberal.
Everyone is like,
you know,
thinking about going Vegan.
You know everyone.
Yeah.
And everyone's unflappable.
Nobody's ever sweating.
Nobody's ever scared.
It's just always got to be confident.
You got to always show people you're
relaxed.
Weird,
weird.
A disconnected and test with your
fucking life.
I've met people that are obsessed with
success,
but they're varied there.
There's a,
there's a fucking sameness to the actor.
The douche.
There's a sameness to them that's
shocking because it doesn't make sense.
Doesn't seem to exist in other things in
people that there's people that develop
like a hardness if like they're in the
financial business,
you know,
there's like a cut throat aspect to like
stocks and bonds and treasuries and
there's a,
there's,
there's similarities,
but they're very more.
The actor is like,
one thing,
you know,
it's like Strip club Dj.
Hey everybody dances on the table.
The big girls come in.
They all have the same voice strip club
Djs have the same voice and actors have
the same or something.
I was thinking about this the other day.
It's not always
you go in,
but when you go in and audition,
there are so many.
It's like watching the fucking
Westminster dog show.
You walk in,
you sign in,
you schmooze with the other actors,
you look at your lines.
Then when you walk in you got to say
something clever and you a mile
flirtation with the casting director.
Then you say something that's a little
bit naughty and then you start the scene
and then you finish it and they tell you
you're fucking great and you tell them
it's great seeing you walk out like you
don't need the job.
Then you get in your car in the parking
garage and you start slamming your head
against the steering wheel and hating
yourself and then waiting for the call.
Yeah,
I only got into acting for money,
you know,
and I don't.
That's not what I started doing,
stand up for and once I realized that I
can make a living without acting,
you know,
I,
I kind of shied away from,
I don't even act at all for like 10
years until I did a Kevin James Movie.
The zookeeper moving.
Yeah.
I hadn't done anything like 10 years.
I just don't stand up and acting is
work.
That's a job standing up.
It's not a job.
Even when the hard part coming up with
new material and putting together a new
hour and you know,
trying to structure it and you know,
in worrying,
you know,
how are you going to fill time,
how you gonna Start.
Don't,
don't forget anything.
I don't want to go up notes though.
Fuck,
okay.
I got it.
Got It.
That's still the kind of work is nothing
compared to the work of doing somebody
else's
stuff.
Yeah,
because in standup you get back exactly
what you put into it and I find
sometimes I go on the road and I'll be
like,
wow,
I just work two weekends in a row.
I don't have a single new joke.
What the fuck did I just go collect a
paycheck is if I did,
I need to get another line of work
because it's.
I got kids at home that's too precious.
If I'm going to be away,
I got to be creating.
I got to be doing the thing that got me
into the business in the first place and
that's what ultimately leads to more
success.
As you got to go back to that fun,
that danger,
that need you gotta you gotta need it.
When you get up there,
you know,
talking to you today about guys who get
older,
they lose.
They're funny because they get too,
too rich,
too comfortable.
They don't need it when they get up.
Well,
we were talking,
we were playing pool about bands that
just no one even wants to hear any other
new shit.
Yeah.
But then other bands,
every time there's a new blank album,
you know,
people are interested like the rolling
stones released an album recently.
You did you know that was it a rerelease
of old stuff?
I don't know.
Somebody told me that the role I should
should be sure before I say that.
Well,
spring one and I can't wait to get it.
I heard that there.
It's good.
People have been saying that.
I think I feel the same way about the
chili peppers.
I still and some people,
a lot of people disagree.
I think that they're putting out their
best stuff now.
California cation is a great fucking
song.
Has a great song.
That was a member,
Brian,
when we were in Phoenix.
That was like the theme song for
Phoenix.
It would just come out.
It was so good.
We're like,
play it again.
Play that shit again.
Yeah.
They got another new album that came out
about six months ago.
That's dynamite.
Subcategories.
That doesn't have it.
I'm looking at their albums coming up
next.
We got the Chili peppers that you
followed by the stones.
New CD CT bed on stage.
How many guys get to do that voice?
There's a lot of guys that make a living
doing that voice.
My Dad was one really.
Well,
he was a.
He was a.
well,
he was a broadcaster.
He's doing,
he did exactly what we're doing right
now,
except he introduced records.
He wasn't a cheese ball,
but he was one of the biggest disc
jockeys in New York for 20 years.
Wow.
So you grew up with that?
Yeah.
I grew up going in and watching them
have show business.
You grew up like looking at it?
Yeah,
he was famous in New York.
I mean we couldn't walk down the street.
Everybody fits a hey fits,
you know,
and yeah,
it was pretty cool and kind of talk
radio that he'd do.
He did real liberal spewing hate
callers,
you know,
people that couldn't stand him and he'd
take them on and he was tough guy from
the bronx and he could back it up.
Smart Guy.
You remember that?
That was like the only time audience
members could interact before twitter.
You know,
now people get fucking shit on you when
people used to be able to catch you on
the phone.
Yeah.
I just want to say I think you're a
fucking bum.
Yeah.
It'd be able to call you,
hop like,
oh,
we're going to go to the phone calls.
All they're bubbling with anger,
you know,
you could pretty much be filtered from
most of them unless you went on a few
shows.
Well,
I get the,
uh,
I,
I do a show still on Sirius xm on
stearns channel and nate,
we get a call screen that shows me like
whatever,
seven or eight calls their name,
where they're from,
what they want to talk about.
And if it says thanks,
you're a piece of shit and you suck.
Like,
hey,
how you doing bill and Denver,
those are the only calls I take.
I love it because I know that after two
or three minutes they're going to go up
fucking around and do it.
I love you.
Or just silence and a hang up because
they couldn't back up.
They're opening fucking barrage.
They couldn't back up.
Hey Greg,
I should preface this by saying,
Greg,
Greg is a one of those guys will every
now and then,
like today or yesterday,
I got a message from who the fuck is
this guy?
Some guy on twitter that's given them a
hard time.
Do you know what this fucking guy is?
I'll tell you what these fucking cowards
face to face,
like actually you actually get you pull
your pants.
I'm going to get off my lawn.
You actually,
you will fucking.
You'll engage them.
I must got in a fistfight the other day.
Whoa.
Onstage.
Other night I was in Chicago,
did get into a
fistfight in Boston.
Many,
many in Boston at the stitches.
Didn't some guy come on stage and you
got in a fistfight with them.
This.
They separate you.
Everything gets separated and then greg
goes,
all right,
next.
I got my ass kicked.
Yeah,
he's fucking.
He's just gonna
the army and he's spinning me around
like a fucking helicopter.
No video.
The guy with the guitar,
some guy beat the fucking dude in the
audience over the head with a guitar.
And that was back when people didn't
videotape shit.
That was magic because it was actually
nowadays you probably can find that all
over the places.
That was legendary,
but no,
I still get into fistfights.
This guy was heckling me from the.
He heckled me.
I'm new.
This joke about Hispanics and he goes,
it goes back off.
I go,
what?
Back off I go,
what do you talk about?
Fun.
And I asked for a wireless mic for this
exact reason.
I can fucking walk right off.
He's in the back row places pack.
Walk right up to his table.
What are you saying?
You don't need to be talking about
Hispanics.
I go,
I just shit on Jewish people.
Chinese people,
Irish people,
black people.
You're relaxed in line.
I'm not even attack and nothing.
And he's,
he's fucking fist clench looking at me.
I go,
come on man.
Come on.
Come on man.
And I just fucking eye contact.
I don't know what it is.
I am gone.
I get crazy Irish,
Irish and I think it's also on stage.
That's my fucking stage,
man.
You're not,
you're in the audience now.
Yeah,
I remember I had a joke about Roswell,
New Mexico about the UFO crash and about
how the government.
They're printed in the paper.
I actually have a day's newspaper,
the Roswell daily record.
It's at my house in a frame.
And uh,
you know,
it's sad.
We have recovered a flying disc that you
had.
The government says,
you know,
this is the first captured flying
saucer.
Then the next day they said,
oh,
it was just a balloon.
I go,
what about the aliens?
those are Mexicans.
Apparently they opened the balloon.
They were drinking,
so shenanigans took place,
but they thought it was a Yada.
This chick stands up at the comedy store
is like,
don't be fucking talking about Mexicans.
We fucking talking about me.
I go,
did you even listen to what I said?
Like,
I'm not even making fun of Mexicans.
I'm making fun of the government for,
for a,
a lame,
you know an excuse for this crashed ufo.
You need a simple joke about the word
aliens having two meetings.
Yeah.
Not really much deeper than that.
It's Christ,
but no,
I hit a hot mess.
Some people are so stupid.
Just the word is a hot button.
Oh,
this is my favorite.
I'm doing a college and I do this joke.
It's probably.
You probably remember,
it is this fucking way long ago,
and I said in college I was on the crew
team,
the rowing team,
and I didn't know anything about the
sport except what I've seen those
ancient Roman slave ship movies.
So I showed up for the first day of
practice with a big drama in a whip and
we won the league that year and we
captured one of Harvard ships,
sold them off as slaves and the Adriatic
say stupid joke and exactly kind of joke
you probably hated me for when I was
kinda clever.
Not that funny.
So paranoid.
Hate you for,
you know.
So I'm at the college.
I do that joke and this fucking black
chick goes,
you don't do no fucking jokes about
slaves.
And I go,
Ma'am Ma'am,
collect yourself.
Number one,
talking about Roman slaves.
There were white.
He didn't corner the market on slavery.
Sit down.
Oh,
and fucking she wouldn't stop.
Wouldn't stop in the face of a fact that
went against her whole fucking.
So what are you saying that slavery has
never existed or that because blacks
have been one of the groups that has
been subjugated into slavery,
that you're defending all slavery.
Is it just not on the table?
It should not be discussed because
you're a college where you're supposed
to discussion and break it down and I
just went off on that rant.
Well,
I've found that colleges were more pc or
more,
more like restricted and censored than
anywhere.
People will get upset if you would bring
up anything controversial,
look at the board.
Anything racial,
anything racial,
anything sexist,
anything homophobic,
but you can't.
There's a difference between racist and
racial.
Does the difference between discussing
homosexuality and homophobic and they
can't make that distinction.
It's all buzzwords and just real,
you know,
real facts about humanity that people
don't want you to talk about when it
comes to,
you know,
a bunch of different race.
It's fascinating.
It's part of a.
You know,
what's interesting about life is
discussing what different people do in
different parts of the world.
You know,
and I love that when you bring up
religion onstage and somebody gets
upset,
like I'll say I don't believe in the 10
commandments and then you see somebody
crossed her arms and get pissed and I
just stopped to.
Okay,
hold on lady.
Am I a preacher?
Did you hire me to fucking lecture?
I'm a Dick joke comic.
I tell jokes to drunks.
If you're looking at me as the guidance
in you or anybody else's life,
you're a fucking idiot.
You know,
I'm a comic.
We're the lowest,
the lowest fucking form of speech in
society.
You know,
we're not supposed to talk radio's lower
than us.
Go Fill Henry.
Well that's good.
He's really good.
Just coming on my show next week.
Is He,
he's a professional troll to Gretchen's.
Been up to lately.
Troll before the Internet.
He's doing a,
I think he's got a lot of podcast stuff,
website,
but he's doing.
He's still got an am show going in am
radio as well.
Our Bro.
Like the highbrow.
Well now you know they're doing a lot of
sports is going to fm now.
Sports talk really because people want
to hear sports talk,
but young generations don't even tune
into him.
They just don't.
They don't even look.
Yeah,
so it's like,
am was just losing v listeners.
People are dying off.
He had.
The only time I've ever put on aim is to
hear a sports game,
which is where,
because I don't listen to sports for
traffic and news.
Like if you're in your car and you're
like,
shit,
I need to know what's going on because
they always have like that every 10
minutes.
I only used to listen to when our bill
was on the art bell was on.
I am.
I'd be coming home from the comedy store
at 1:00
in
the morning,
listen to art bell,
talking to some dude who
just got here from Mars.
Hard the best fucking show ever for
driving by yourself late at night,
you know,
because it was always some fucking Ufo
shit or cloning or pre podcast.
So you can listen to something different
if you.
Yeah.
But it was nothing like that on the air.
You know,
like you could actually get your call
through because it's late at night on a
and it's got three guys on the line
tops.
Well,
didn't he have a guy who called and said
that he was in area 50?
I'm calling from area 51 there and then
like at the end he like yells and hangs
up the phone and saying that they
fucking captured.
I'm just trying to tell them where they
all the UFO was.
Our and all those security that we've
got down here.
We have seven craft.
I can't believe I'm telling you this for
77 shape crafts operate.
We don't understand what it is they send
us in here to back engineer.
I'm sure going.
Let me just hang up the phone
wells all over again.
I probably was Phil Henry.
What do you think in terms of.
All right,
you got a big podcast?
I have A.
I have a fairly big podcast,
but I feel like what the fuck?
The future possibly hold.
Accept this free form.
A all content.
No restriction radio.
How does that compare for free?
Anywhere you want it,
you can download it.
Listen,
when you want pause it.
How does that compare to.
I gotta have it on it's streaming live.
It's censored.
This like how do you think in 10 years
people are going to listen because it
started as radio.
It's becoming.
Then it was satellite podcasting.
Do you think this is the one that's
going to hold?
Well,
I think there's a place for this.
You know,
and this isn't the ultimate thing to sit
when you're home with your girl and you
want to watch something on TV.
You don't want to sit and watch a
fucking podcast,
you know?
I mean that's weird to sit and watch
conversation.
I think you maybe want to watch a movie
or do you want to watch a sitcom or.
But for times,
especially when you're doing boring
labor,
you know,
like you're fucking stacking boxes and
shit.
Like there's a lot of people that are
listening to this right now that are
working jobs.
Yeah.
And they either have an ipod on or they
have a little,
you know,
a,
a player somewhere where it's a,
you know,
an MP,
three player or whatever the fuck it is.
And they're there listening to this
while they're driving in their cars,
they'll listen to this while they're on
planes.
There's a place for this form of
entertainment,
you know,
and that's why I really don't have any
desire to do anything else.
You know,
I've,
I've thought about doing other different
sorts of TV projects,
but really the best thing that I do is
like this and stand up and then the UFC,
that's like enough stuff to venture off
into more acting as well.
Yeah.
Just pretending,
you know.
Yeah.
When I,
when I look at the fact that in standup
and podcasting,
I can literally say anything except
killed the president.
It's mindbody.
What did you just,
he's not mit is not president yet to
say.
I think I can say kill Mitt Romney.
Oh,
you can't,
you cannot know he's running for
president.
I'm just saying in theory.
Um,
but I guess my,
my question really though is like,
do you think that eventually it's going
to be like you're going to turn on your
radio in your car and it's going to be
podcasts streaming or a Ford edge or
Ford has the sync.
Which has like a three g built into it
and you can download like stitcher and
content and you need to get off
stitcher.
I got off it.
I've gotten a little off it.
I've gotten everybody off it because
they steal your content.
They cut and paste it.
You don't get any record of the
downloads.
They've got charts and records they
didn't use to end.
They're running ads.
They're running banner ads on your
content,
so this advertising going on your
content that you're not participating
in.
Yeah,
those little itunes ads,
those are million dollar ad.
I don't know what it is,
but this is what I know.
This is what I know.
Stitcher is an easy resource to put
something out that's already free.
My thing is already free and stitcher
allows more people to get my free shit
and that's how I look at it.
A lot of people like it.
They use it.
I think it's a good deal.
To me it's just another distribution
platform.
My advertisement is in on it.com,
which I owned part of and in the
fleshlight,
which has been our sponsor since we were
on a laptop with fucking snowflakes in
the background,
you know,
so for me,
I liked stitcher.
I liked the fact that it gets to other
people.
Some people don't like it because it can
mess with your itunes,
your ratings,
your itunes numbers,
but we're always in the top 10 and we
have,
we have every way you can get it,
you can download it as a free MP.
Three,
you can have it through it,
an rss feed.
You can have it through Stitcher,
you can have it through you stream,
you can have it through vimeo.
You know we have it on itunes.
You can.
We make it as as readily available as
you can get a copy of throat up on
torrents.
Who Cares?
Do whatever you want with it.
It's out there,
but if you had,
say you had a CD,
right?
Somebody buys it,
that's different.
All right,
say somebody a say.
I mean,
to me it doesn't even need a metaphor
for content is being taken and sold.
It stays here.
They have done a service for me and
they've distributed to me to eat for do
that service,
but I'm already doing that service and
they have expanded my market.
They've,
they've given more people something that
I do and have a great product that I do
for free anyway and I only do this.
I only do it for free,
so if more people get my free podcast,
good.
So if somebody is making a couple bucks
selling little ads in order to
distribute my podcast,
that's what it's worth to them.
I guess for me,
my issue is I have ads that I get paid
per download and that they weren't
giving me the count on those,
so that was taking money out of my
pocket and then on top of it when I
found out that they were running ads on
my content,
that's double.
That's a double whammy and to me it's
like the more guys that are on Stitcher,
the more people just go,
well fuck it.
I'm just going to listen to podcast on
stitcher instead of people going,
I'm not going to be on this thing
because it's a bad business.
You have a different sort of a take on
it.
You know,
my take on it is a,
uh,
not based on.
I didn't have a thing that would pay me
based on downloads,
so that makes more sense that you'd be
pissed.
Yeah.
But you know,
you have the numbers,
you can give them those numbers of those
downloads.
I use stitcher so
much because I liked the software,
you know,
that would actually be thing if you
could work it into,
that'd be like the best solution.
Like it looks.
I still have additional downloads
outside of itunes.
Can we incorporate?
Yeah.
Why wouldn't you?
Because they're still legitimate
listeners.
Yeah,
that's a good point.
I guess they,
I got myth because I only found,
I found out about it and I emailed them.
They didn't respond and then when they
finally did,
they denied it and then when they were
found to be,
oh no,
yeah,
we do do that,
but we'll give you like a penny per
million.
And it's like,
first of all,
don't make me an offer now that you've
already stolen it and sold it and made
money and now now you want to negotiate
and give me a shitty offer.
So I just thought these are bad people,
these are not.
And I've had the same conversation with
a number of big podcast who's who had
the same experience they do when they
confronted them,
they denied it,
they made shitty offers,
they were disrespectful.
And it's to me,
it's setting up a business model to say
down the road you do this.
Say you do.
Just say fuck it.
I'm doing four podcasts a week and I'm
not gonna go on the road,
I'm going to sell ads.
Now all the sudden there's gonna be
other,
a aggregator sites like stitcher that
I've already called your rss feed.
Copied and pasted it.
So it's not connected.
And you're not getting counts public or
rss feeds on your website?
Yes,
but they have to be,
you know,
they have to stream through the my rss
feed.
They can't just scream your rss feed
though than that.
But they don't.
No,
no.
I mean the and that means that you're
just saying that any player can do the
same,
think,
stitcher,
we cannot have another artist argument.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
let's do that.
Let's talk about the.
Goddamn it's,
but it is.
It is an important point that you're
bringing up and especially what you were
saying that you know,
you were getting paid by the download
and I didn't.
I didn't have any experience with
negotiating with them because to me it
was nothing but a good thing,
so I didn't get to experience the lying
or the whatever you say you experienced.
I didn't get to experience that because
my take was right away was like,
okay,
good.
Then we'll now more people can hear it.
We have hundreds of thousands of people
that listen outside of Itunes,
so for us it's to have the more
distribution that way.
Better institutions is actually really
good people.
I had dinner with the president and he
was giving them free content.
No,
no,
no.
I probably love you.
I'm giving free content out to every
single person in the world and they just
happen to have the,
a player that,
that they,
uh,
use it does the same thing in my mind.
Am I see,
I don't get what you and a few of the
other podcasts you guys are saying
because you're,
you're giving something for free out.
Didn't you have an argument with
somebody?
Fuck it.
I don't want to go down there.
That's just saying that I said my piece,
you,
we're both,
we're both going after different things
with the podcast and I guess there's a,
there's going to be.
Look,
we're finding,
you know,
podcasting is finding its footing and
how it's going to be delivered and this
will be an ongoing discussion and see.
See what makes most sense and what's the
most ethical.
Yeah.
I mean a bunch of guys are doing
different things.
Like Marin I know has a thing where you
can't get as old ones unless you pay
your premium listeners premium,
you know you're done.
Yeah.
I just think he's done really well with
that.
Yeah.
But it seems me like you charge someone
for something that you also have for
free,
like why not just have it for free.
He's just trying to find new ways to
make money.
I know it seems weird,
like you know,
like the old ones they have to pay for
the old ones.
Like what's that?
You want them to get all your stuff if
you want any of it free.
I just,
it seems to me that it should all be
free.
Well I think so to a point.
I think that with a lot of times with
premium membership,
they take out the commercials,
you know,
a lot of times like I have,
I have something to give away for free,
which is like the best fits dog radio
and it's just,
I got like five or six like Zach
Galifianakis and Jimmy Kimmel,
like some bigger names and I sort of
took the best five,
six,
eight minutes from each as a way of just
promoting the shell.
I'm putting it out there.
Originally I was thinking,
oh,
I should make a bunch of best ofs and
sell them.
And I went,
no,
that doesn't make sense.
I'd rather drive people.
It's all about building.
I just want more and more people to
experience it.
They like it.
Keep listening.
If not,
they tried it.
Well we w we started doing is Brian
started that desk squad network of
podcasts just for that very reason when
I was telling you about at the pool hall
to try to expand,
to use the popularity of this podcast to
promote the pop to make that more
popular and sort of launched all these
little different guys off into their own
little podcast world.
Yeah.
And you know,
because of podcasts,
a lot of our friends are like making a
living now that weren't making a living
out.
It's great.
And they've done it in red.
Well they've done a true content
marketing,
you know,
like their name or their last comic
standing appearance.
But actually know you've listened hour
after hour to me and now you're going to
be inclined to come back.
Yeah.
They'd love to come see it.
Like Joey Diaz,
apparently they did a gig up in upstate
New York.
Joe,
he got a standing ovation from the
entire fucking room.
They just went.
They freaked out.
As soon as I saw he's a star.
That's amazing.
He should have been like that a long
time ago.
He needed something like a podcast to
really let the audience see who the fuck
he really was.
The day that Whitney Houston died,
I put a.
I said in honor of the death of the
Great Whitney Houston.
Here's a video of Joey Diaz talking
about selling coke to her days day.
She died.
I totally should have done it.
It was so rude.
She.
You get a lot of shit about it.
No,
no.
Look,
if that was one that everybody saw,
comment.
I mean that was ridiculous.
I mean,
Whitney Houston had that TV show with
Bobby Brown.
Do you remember?
Crack is whack.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
They'd be screaming.
It was chaos.
They'd be screaming at each.
Remember when she would.
They would be.
I said,
they didn't say,
how dare you?
How dare you?
A baby screaming if that's offensive to
some people.
You can't even say that.
They'd be screaming,
you can't talk like that.
You can.
I great.
Maybe talk lot.
Yeah.
You're not allowed to.
Not Allowed to say that.
I find the more I say it,
the more I'm allowed to.
It's all about saying a lot.
You have to like stay wet.
It's like,
you know when you get out of the pool
and you dry off and then you don't want
to go back in to stay wet.
Say attack
are slowly being diminished.
Yeah.
You know,
someone talked about the Jeremy Lin
incident where a reporter got in trouble
for saying a chicken in his either
accidentally.
He wasn't saying it as a joke.
It slipped out.
That is what you say.
It's not so we're supposed to run every
fucking thing we say through the prism
of political correctness and who I how.
How do you talk craziness will or unless
the guy was trying to be cute because
then you have to say if the guy was just
trying to be cute.
Yeah.
That's kind of a douchey thing to do.
If the guy was just trying.
I mean he,
he's never really gonna admit it.
He's not going to say,
look,
I was trying to be cute.
I got caught,
whatever.
I said,
Jake.
Yeah,
yeah.
He's a Chinese guy,
you know,
but um,
people,
people were upset enough that that guy
like he got suspended.
Right.
You hired,
I think the writer,
somebody wrote it
and then he said it.
I think the broadcaster might've gotten
suspended or I got his wrist slap.
But I think the guy who wrote it into
the copy
godfather was fired.
Well,
he was probably trying to be cute if he
wrote it,
actually wrote it down.
Come on.
When you write things,
you think about them way more than just
saying it's hard to think he didn't
catch that.
I said kamikaze this weekend in Japan
during a fight and it was totally
accidental.
Guy was losing,
but it's okay.
It kamikaze is not like in Japan,
like St Kamikaze in Japan is not like
calling someone a check.
It's like that.
Those are like,
they're revered warriors.
They risk their lives like their,
their,
their brain stumped on extinguish them
while they're pretty sure that rather I.
and they were correct,
but there was a dude who was losing and
I said,
look,
he's losing he,
the only way he's going to win this
fight is if he goes just fucking
kamikaze.
Adam.
No,
I didn't even think about it until
somebody wrote it online.
I can't believe Rogan said kamikaze.
That's what I would say.
That's what I would always say.
You gotta just go kill or be killed.
Go in there and dive bomb on them.
No,
I write on a lot of black shows for some
reason I've written on like for black
shows.
And I always say shit.
Well Wanda Sykes and uh,
cedric the entertainer presents.
That was the first guy I ever got.
Louis brought me out of that.
And um,
and then I wrote on Jamie Foxx show this
past spring.
And so every time I come in it's like,
because I'm white and it's almost always
like all,
like the Jamie Foxx thing.
I was the only white guy and I was
brought in.
Things weren't going well.
And then they brought me in and you
think to try to
help out what was the Jamie Foxx thing?
It was this guy named Don crocket had a
sketch show that Jamie Foxx was
producing and um,
you know,
it was a late night talk show and uh,
everything I said was taken like,
oh,
you gotta say whip like let's whipped us
into shape kind of thing.
And it was always like,
oh,
there he goes again.
They were calling me Mr Magoo because I
would just blindly walk into things.
It was funny,
like nobody was offended,
but it was like the running joke is that
it's so easy to just say the wrong
fucking thing.
No,
it was hilarious.
It was like classic ball busting and it.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
no,
it's,
it's hard man,
because I really do feel like every time
you put a take it off the table,
you're taking the idea off the table.
What you're really doing is saying,
no,
we're not allowed to,
um,
explore,
discuss,
dissect,
and possibly deflate an idea.
We have to just pretend it's not there
because we,
because it's just,
I don't know.
Um,
I don't know where political correctness
even comes from,
you know,
who came up with the idea that people go
to college where you're supposed to open
your mind and then tell a comedian that
he can't tell a bunch of 20 year olds.
You can't say,
fuck,
I can't say fuck in front of a bunch of
20 year olds.
All they do is fuck and drink and,
and I can't talk about drinking or
fucking why am I here?
Why are you,
why are you charging them 30 grand a
year for what?
To protect them from ideas at college.
Do you know that like the board of
governors of every major university is
overwhelmingly a occupied by fortune
500,
uh,
board members.
Really?
Yeah,
it is.
College is there to create middle
managers.
It's there to double down anybody.
It's going to challenge the status quo.
My Wife's dad is a bit of a ruined
neighborhoods.
All the Ivy League schools are the worst
fucking neighborhood.
Columbia or Harvard.
Yale gets shot and stabbed anywhere near
Harvard.
Berkeley,
I think at one point was a bad
neighborhood.
I think it's good now.
Burglary as good.
No.
Yeah.
But it's close to Oakland,
right?
Isn't it?
Yes.
Yeah,
it's Oakland and then Berkeley.
So,
but the point is my,
my wife's dad who graduated number one
in his class from Yale,
got a,
became a medical,
got a medical degree,
ran for president on the Green Party in
California in 2000 and got close to
Nader.
Brilliant fucking guy.
His textbooks are published all over the
world.
Uh,
he had the Algebra,
his chair in sociology at Bard College,
very progressive liberal Jewish school
in New York.
And he wrote a book that was anti
Zionist and his opinion,
uh,
Israel is a terrorist state that has a
attacked,
uh,
the Palestinians and,
and you know,
he lost his chair who was fired because
the alumni didn't like his view.
Wow.
What the fuck is a college supposed to
be?
Discourse argument,
but that's not what it is.
It's just preparing people for work.
Yes.
I mean it's sort of discourse and
argument,
but it's also preparing you for work,
for what work.
I mean,
if you look at the future of this
country,
where is the work coming from?
It ain't coming from the fucking auto
factories.
It ain't coming from the farms.
We don't know where it's coming from.
It's going to come from mines that have
gone into the depths of challenged ideas
and come out of it with the tools to
take the status quo and change it and
create and develop.
I couldn't imagine even existing and
going to school in the age of the
Internet.
It must be so fucking different.
I know it must be so different because
you can't stop anybody from googling
anything at anytime.
The teacher
can't be full of Shit,
you know,
everyone has to.
Everything has to be checked and the
information that's passing so quickly.
No,
I,
you can go to classes.
I forgot I'm talking to somebody in
college and they were gonna.
They were gonna sit down and open up
their laptop to watch the class that
they'd missed because they videotaped
the lectures and you can just download
them.
So you're,
you know,
you got an 8:00
class in January and Boston,
you're going to get out of bed.
Fuck,
now you wait two hours and you watch it
on your computer,
so why are you in Boston paying for a
dorm room and all this shit.
Just go to a.
what's the,
what's the online university?
What is the Phoenix,
Phoenix University of Phoenix or
wherever
mit offers the offer.
A lot of their lectures available online
as well.
Like there's a lot of like you can
literally get.
I mean,
there was like the education joke in
the,
uh,
was the movie with Damon Matt Damon in a
strip tease the fucking Boston boys.
Matt Damon showed me the Appalachian
identity goes.
That's about Cinderella one.
Who's the one who married a Jennifer
Lopez?
AFLAC.
Ben.
What?
Goodwill hunting.
Good will go and help them.
Remember he was talking about his
Harvard education and he was just joking
about.
Yeah,
you get that with a library card.
no,
that,
it's kind of like in Boston he talked
about like going to harvard versus
another school and it's how much better
it is.
It's like,
what do they have professors at other
schools that go,
sorry,
I can't teach you that.
You got to go to Harvard to learn that.
I mean,
I'm sure it's just more competitive,
right?
Well,
I think it's.
You know what it is.
It's about,
it's about networking.
You're going to go to school with kids
whose dads went to Harvard and I could
afford to pay this and who had the juice
to get you in and you're going to those
are there going to be your cohorts as
you grow older,
you want to call in a favor.
You want to call a friend from fucking a
University of Phoenix or from Harvard
who's going to,
who's going to help you out more
and it's.
Yeah,
and they're most likely all going to be
successful as well as they get older.
And what's really interesting is those
guys that get into like secret societies
when they're in college,
skull and crossbones,
that's real.
That's fucking real.
Those Ivy League schools,
like really high end schools,
the Illuminati all send their kids to.
They really do joined secret societies
like the skull and bones.
They look really do like weird gay shit
to each other and the blokes and robes
can hit each other and they do a lot
more out on the surface.
They're called dinner clubs at Harvard
and you,
you try to get into a dinner club and
it's just,
it's a,
it's a more transparent version of skull
and bones,
but it's the same thing.
These are my boys.
We're gonna Watch each other's backs,
you know,
in college beyond college.
And,
and the criteria for getting in are
fucking creepy.
They happen at this one happens to be
all Jewish.
This one is all German Jewish.
This one is all,
you know,
uh,
people whose grandparents came over on
the mayflower.
It's all like these specific fucking
clicks.
And it's the same thing I was thinking
like origin based click.
Not always.
I think there's different ways they
distinguish themselves and I'm sure some
of them are based on like,
you know,
this is somebody who works,
has done a lot of community service
work.
So let's have a dinner club,
but a lot of them are based on,
you know,
your blue blood.
You know,
what,
what your DNA is and who your who your
parents were.
And that's the thing also.
But then on the other hand,
like I remember at Boston University
there was like the French house.
It was the gay house,
there was the,
you know,
black house.
It's like,
I thought the idea was that we're all
going to get together and mix it up and
get to know each other.
Why are we fucking secluding this is
segregation.
Yeah.
Certainly is.
I'm against college.
I really am.
I really feel like my kids,
I've got a college savings account.
They got about two years paid for each
at this point and uh,
I don't think I'm putting any more into
it.
And when they turn 17,
I'm going to go.
You get two choices.
You can fucking waste your brain for
junior college or take this money,
joined the circus,
go to Europe backpack.
I don't give a fuck.
But you're gonna you're gonna work,
you know,
you're gonna explore challenge Louis Ck
is mom saved up all this money to send
them to college.
And then when he had a chance,
he went to Nyu film school,
got in,
looked around and said,
well,
I've got an idea for a short film.
Can I take this money and make the film?
I think I can learn more than I can at
the school.
And she thought about it and she gave
him the money.
He made a short film,
got into Sundance.
He ended up as the head writer of the
Conan O'brien show.
And then Chris Rock,
I mean it was like,
you know,
there's other ways to make it in the
world if you really know what you want
besides going to college and being
fucking coddled for years.
Yeah.
Well I always felt like just learning,
like sticking to their lessons.
Like if you,
if you,
you have to have some sort of a base of
education.
You have to be able to express yourself
in the world.
You have to be able to understand
things.
But once you get to a certain point when
you're 17 or 18 years old or you have an
idea of something you want to do,
you know,
if you want to be a gymnast,
you want to be a professional gymnast or
a fucking bike racer,
it's not going to help you to learn
Roman history.
Yeah.
It's really not.
You know when it's in fact going to do,
it's going to take up a lot of time.
It's going to take away.
Some of your folks are doing your other
shit primetime of your youth.
Oh,
you're going to learn.
You're going to be in a band,
but in the meantime you're going to
learn calculus.
No,
you're not.
You know what you're gonna do.
You're gonna have a shitty guitar skill.
You're not.
You're not going to be as good.
Yep.
You're just not.
You're not going to be.
You're not going to get in.
You're gonna.
Be on the outside because you have asked
it.
Yeah.
Now I think you got to go out.
Like I took a year off after high
school.
I never thought I'd go to college and I
traveled around.
I save three grand.
I went to Europe for six months with a
backpack and I came back on like,
wow,
I want to go to college.
There's a lot of Shit I want to learn
and I'm not ready to be out there.
Like I knew I wanted to be a writer and
I want it to go.
I wanted to study great works.
I wanted to learn how to write and I and
I did.
And and I.
It was a great experience for me.
I wouldn't have known it if I'd gone
straight in from high school.
And I also think that like a boss sees
should be offered earlier in high school
when you're a sophomore,
you may know that you want to be.
But Oh,
in New York they call it both sees.
It's like a vocational school.
Like if you know you don't want to learn
calculus and you're a sophomore,
you can start going to cooking classes
are small engine repair and by the time
you graduated high school you're
qualified to be a chef or a,
you know,
a lead mechanic and eventually own a
shop.
Yeah.
But a lot of people don't want their
kids to be boxed in like that because
then if the kid grows up and then
eventually wants to actually go to
college,
well now he doesn't even have the base
for it and he can't even compete.
No.
You still get your core classes done.
Okay.
But instead of learning,
say a second language,
which you have to do in high school,
you sub out those for these folks.
You go away like three days a week for
half a day to a vocational place.
Learn.
Remember the name.
Now that you're saying that now I
remember.
It sounds like a slander,
but it's actually the name of the
program.
Yeah.
Forgot about that.
Wow.
Yeah.
Well who the fuck knows what they.
I mean,
I didn't figure out what I wanted until
I was 21.
What I wanted to do,
you know,
I really didn't know until I started
doing standup.
Did you go to college?
I went to Umass Boston.
Oh,
you did?
Yeah.
Oh No.
I only went for three years and I only
went because I didn't want people
thinking I was a loser.
Yeah.
So the only reason why I wanted it was
barely paid attention,
a lot of money to not pay attention.
And it was weird.
We know I was um,
you know,
uh,
I would be taking classes and,
you know,
I would,
uh,
like one of them was a weird sociology
class.
This fucking guy.
I'll never forget this guy because he
was from Haiti.
And uh,
no matter what we talked about,
no matter what we talked about when you
talked about the,
the,
the philosophical works with Leonardo
Davinci,
whether it was,
uh,
you know,
anything in was
skinhead.
What we would do is we would say this
and he would always,
no matter what the fuck we talked.
And so that would became,
like,
all I could concentrate on was how many
different things this motherfucker could
connect to Haiti because he always
wanted to hear himself talk because I
think he was learning English.
Yeah.
You know.
So while back in Haiti,
that's all he would say.
And you just want to go,
dude,
you're not in Haiti for a reason.
Why are you trying to draw from that?
Well,
this is the new.
he would wear a tie and suit and tie.
And in college it's crazy.
Yeah.
That's fascinating.
You know,
wanting to argue about everything.
Yeah.
Well the fucking Haitians man,
they like to argue.
That's why I talked to my cab drivers
are either Haitian.
I talked to this guy,
he was a Iranian cab driver the other
day and he's taking me back from the
airport and we start talking about this
and that.
I was,
I was talking to him about,
uh,
you know,
whether or not he thinks that I had
typed,
we're going to bomb Iran.
I go right into it with them,
like,
do you think we're going to bomb Iran?
We get into religion.
And he goes,
you know,
I don't know,
I couldn't be there because they wanted
you to.
He was a Muslim that they wanted you to
believe this and they couldn't accept
it.
I could just believe that it was exactly
the conversation we had earlier about
atheism.
He goes,
I know there's a god.
I know there's a power.
I don't think that man has the capacity
to assign meaning to it or to understand
it.
And I would sit in the back on,
here's an immigrant from Iran who drives
a cab.
I grew up upper middle class in New
York,
college educated.
I'm a comedian and I feel exactly the
same way spiritually as this guy does.
And that's,
that's fucking amazing to me.
You know,
that it all,
when it doesn't matter what culture
you're from,
it transcends that.
It really,
I think if somebody,
like you were saying,
if you really examine yourself when
you're truthful about your,
you know,
uh,
what your reality is,
it comes out there.
There is one human experience I think.
And College to me is supposed to be a
place where they pull that shit out
where they say,
look,
here's four years we can give you a
place to live,
place to eat now,
just fucking go to town on your brain.
You know,
someone needs to
develop a much more unconventional
method of teaching people where they
truly can go towards things only that
they're interested in and know you've
got all your mathematics and everything
already.
Let's,
let's.
This is instead of,
you know,
learning about history,
learning what,
what the fuck do you want to learn about
what he will.
Let me tell you something.
This is will die,
will qualify you for.
Get really good at that.
What are you interested in?
You're interested in this.
Okay,
well let's take you down that road.
But so many people don't even get that
opportunity.
You just,
you're forced to fit into a whole,
whether it's a round hole or a square
hole,
whatever it is,
forced to conform to become whatever,
whatever the fuck that hole is.
And then,
you know,
when you have people that were like,
that girl Jennifer,
that I was dating,
had a restaurant hotel management that
was her major.
And that poor fucking girl,
she went from right out of college to
working 16 hours a day,
every fucking day.
She was always exhausted.
She was always broken down.
And that's what she had to look forward
to.
All the people in the restaurant,
hotel,
bar management world,
those fucking people would work for a
salary.
One salary,
no one got paid overtime and your work
was never done.
And you spent four years not doing that.
So you're behind the people that started
doing the same shit.
You know what?
It's also about technology and uh,
you know,
digital media,
every information and,
and the progress of every industry
changes so fast.
If you're going to college,
you're learning your industry from a guy
who learned it before you started your
learning yesterday's industry.
And then you're going to try to go into
computers or you're going to try to go
into,
you know,
uh,
even acting,
there's different styles of acting.
You go in and get these old acting
teachers that learned from status laskin
you're teaching,
you know,
repeat an answer and repeat.
I fucking suck it audition.
I spent two years at the neighborhood
playhouse in New York and I fucking suck
at auditioning.
I,
I'm a good actor,
but I don't get the chance because I
fucking suck my own dick when I go into
a casting room.
Nobody taught me how to do that because
they were.
They wanted to teach you Russian
theater.
Right.
And it's the same with every industry.
You're learning the fucking dinosaur
method of things.
Yeah.
That used to be the way it was with
martial arts to the ultimate fighting
championship sort of came around.
Everybody was learning this old style
of,
of doing things where it had been.
It already evolved past that should've
been.
Should've been in a completely different
stratosphere,
but everybody was holding onto the
traditional methods and no one was
exchanging information.
Yeah.
Who was the first person?
Who would you say is the first pioneer
in that kind of crossover?
Mixed signals.
Significant
guys hoists gracie because he was the
guy that won the first ultimate fighting
championship and he won it in a way that
proved that a smaller man with more
skill could defeat a bigger man because
that was always the goal of martial arts
was like the Bruce Lee thing where this
little guy could fuck up everybody,
but the reality is in striking,
that really doesn't work because little
people can't hit us hard.
They just can't.
You know what I mean?
The little guy who can kick kick you in
the face.
Yeah,
it can hurt you,
but the reality is most fights end up on
the ground and the little guy might
throw a kick and slip because the
fucking beer bottle fell on the floor
and there's water everywhere and you
don't have the footing to throw.
Fucking wild head kicks in the middle of
a bar.
But when push comes to shove and tangle
and you go to the ground,
then you have to understand how to
grapple and what the Jujitsu that hoists
gracie had when he fought in the UFC was
Brazilian Jujitsu and no one here knew
what the fuck that was.
Dudes had no idea what that guy was.
But UFC at that point was.
That was.
That was chain link fences and it lives
in another country,
right?
Well,
no,
it was denver,
Colorado was the first one.
Okay.
You know,
it was put together by Horian Gracie who
is his older brother who was a lawyer,
a very smart guy.
What year is this?
About?
Nineteen 93.
Yeah.
And that changed everything because my
whole life I had been a striker,
I'd done kickboxing and taekwondo.
It was all striking and this was the
first time that I had seen like what
could happen with submissions.
I've wrestled in high school,
but I never really pursued it at much
after the one year in high school.
I never learned any choke hold or
anything like that and learn it and
seeing this guy just dismantle people on
the ground.
You'd be like,
Holy Shit.
Like what would I do?
All these other guys,
these big strong guys getting strangled.
What'd I do?
He strangled me to,
you know,
it was inescapable conclusion.
I saw it.
I was like,
the inescapable conclusion is if you
didn't know what this guy knew and you
got let him get ahold of you,
you're fucked.
So.
But.
So he changed it the most.
But in terms of like what we're talking
about,
which is that when you try to,
when you try to do things differently,
people will try to stop,
you know,
UFC still.
It's still trying to fight off the
stigma that it's this vicious back
alley,
you know?
Not too brutal,
but it wasn't this year,
kind of a big test for UFC.
Going to that next level and going on
network.
Yeah,
because it came on Fox.
It is completely up the profile and
visit a success.
Did it succeed?
Yes,
and Fox is really enthusiastic about it.
They have a big longterm deal and
they've seen the UFC develop over the
years and it took a long time before
they got interested in,
but they got interested in it at the
perfect time because the product is so
developed.
The brand so developed.
The fighters are so high level now.
I mean the referees are great.
Everybody's safety's at the all time
high.
As far as
broadcasting is state of the art.
It's easiest.
Fuck.
It's the.
That's the easiest.
Easy because you love it and you know
it.
It's very easy.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a.
it's a fun,
exciting thing to do,
but it's like for me it's natural.
It's convinced.
Some guys don't seem like I watch Jim
Rome.
I know a lot of people love them.
I feel like he's working.
I don't feel like the guys enjoying what
you do that like it's him.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I know what you mean.
Yeah.
Want a lot of people that don't.
In that world of sport.
That's a bullshit world.
The sports world is full of Shit.
Too many guys in,
in fucking Italian suits talking about
something that get basically the same
type of talking.
What we're dealing with here,
you know,
they have this artificial strip club.
Joel,
what do you think next week,
Minnesota against another team.
Which one do you think will win by y and
how many points and why?
And Utah.
Oh my God.
If fucking drink and it's always these x
jocks that are wearing suits and they
look surprised there in a suit.
Oh my God,
I'm going to sue.
I'm going to look at me.
How many yellow suit?
Let's go to the uh,
let's go to the Latino Mulatto chicken.
The field who knows nothing about
sports.
It's hot as fuck.
Always.
They have done on showtime.
When they do strikeforce,
they have hot girls at interview the
fighters and they put together,
you know,
they,
they do a good job.
They put together some questions and
they feed them to her and then she,
you know,
she knows a little bit about the sports.
You could banter a little bit if she has
to,
but the most important thing,
she's hot.
Yeah.
Look,
yeah,
look,
he did this.
Mix it up a little.
Yeah,
a sweaty guy with a hot check.
I got lucky with the UFC and that I got
in before it was ever a big market.
That's the second big wave you've caught
in your life.
I'm lucky as fuck.
Yeah.
Always been lucky but not lucky.
I mean,
I was going to say this to you before
and we were playing pool when young
comics ask for advice,
I just want to say to them,
live a life,
do something,
you know,
don't just fucking write notes and go on
stage and then,
you know,
talk about your cubicle job and go
travel,
go.
You know,
they follow your path.
You've always stayed with martial arts
and then all a sudden this thing comes
up and it wasn't lucky.
It was the fact that you had.
I'm honored your,
your passion.
Not just in being a standup but in life.
And that's what I say to young comics.
Like go,
you know,
like me,
I got married and I kid.
That's something I really wanted.
I love,
I'm into.
I talk about it onstage and you,
you see people go,
oh,
I'm not going to be one of those.
Go talk about my kids on stage.
It's like it doesn't matter when I talk
about I'm saying it.
Anybody can make a topic interesting.
If it's truthful and real.
That's a weird thing that people do when
they believe that somehow or another.
If you talk about children,
like all of a sudden you've fallen into
this soul sell out,
like really pacified sort of a wishy
washy sort of stand up.
Like you abandoned the possibility that
anything could actually be really funny
about having kids when in fact it's
funny shit that happens all the time.
Yup.
Well not just funny,
but it's perspective.
It's existential,
you know,
I mean you're talking about life here.
There's going to get any deeper than
having looking at your son.
Like,
I'm going through this thing now where
my kid is like,
I'll tell you,
he's testing for his black belt in
taekwondo in the spring after fucking
seven years.
Uh,
he's 11 years old.
He's captain of the soccer team,
straight a student.
He is fluent in Spanish because to a
Spanish immersion school.
He's the tallest kid in his class.
It's fucking beautiful looking.
And I go,
I need a DNA test.
No,
I don't fucking do.
Don't believe it.
Who?
I'm the opposite of that Short,
scrawny,
horrible athlete.
Horrible fucking student.
Maybe it's the hormones and the beef
could be.
It could be.
Kids are getting way bigger.
There are 100 percent.
They're bigger.
The girls are having their periods and
so I'm going through this thing.
Land Connor,
good dad.
You raised them.
Well,
I mean that's,
that's a good sign.
It is a good sign.
I'm proud of that and it's also.
But it's,
it's a great premise.
Like I know my kid's going to be
stronger and smarter than me soon and
it's fucking scary and I'm trying to
think,
how do I hide it from,
Oh,
you don't have to just be a great dad.
You don't have to look my.
You're using a belt.
I was a few late.
I'll hit me back.
Getting older.
There was always a,
these old martial arts guys that were
around that were treated with great
reverence.
You know,
you could easily kick their ass.
They're old,
they're old and broken down,
but you never thought of that because
you had always developed great reverence
for them.
Just as long as you develop respect your
kid,
your kid's never going to challenge.
You're going to have to deal with it.
Shit,
I never.
It's a very based biological.
I think it's just like a real in the
wild kind of thing.
It is a little bit,
but you know,
once you just got to calm that down by
letting them know that you're on his
team,
you know,
and letting them know that everything
that you do to discipline him is only
for his own development.
It seems weird,
but you went through it just as much as
he is.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
And it is hard because as the dad,
and I don't know how deep you are into
that part is like,
I feel like I have to be that,
you know,
it's a role.
She ended up being the disciplinarian
more than my wife does.
Yeah,
of course.
Well,
you know,
there's a balance.
There's a yin and a Yang and there's a
mom and dad and just the way it is and
you know,
you should be.
I mean,
my point of view is you should be as
loving as possible,
but the shit stops with me and you know,
that's how it's always supposed to be.
That's how it isn't a fucking gorilla
colony.
When,
when,
when everybody's going crazy and fucking
swinging off trees and the grill goes,
everybody settle the fuck down.
Alright.
Demands here we got this.
Let's calm down.
Yeah,
you can learn a lot about parenting from
the dog guy.
What's his name?
The kick your kids.
Everything.
He said,
well say takes the dog.
Oh,
I didn't know that.
You didn't know that.
Now I just knew this whole pack
mentality saying is kick them.
He just taps him on the side.
No,
no.
He heals them in the gut and if you did
it to me,
I'd punch him in his fucking face.
Reality kick is a kick.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what the reality is though,
people don't want to hear.
You have to be physical with dogs.
You know?
I know I never hit my dogs,
but I used to raise pit bulls and the
one thing you have to do is you have to
dominate.
Those motherfuckers are used to slam on
their back.
I used to mount them and bite them,
bite their face and yell at them because
if they growl at you a little man,
you have to cease and desist that when
they're a puppy,
you have to make sure that you make them
know that you are.
You are dominant over them,
but you're loving to them.
Do you control them?
Like,
listen,
bitch,
when you ever fucking do that again.
Okay.
Yeah,
we good Gimme Gimme kiss,
yeah.
Yeah.
And too little pussy dogs,
but one of them is a buyer and I just
grab her by the scruff of the neck and I
pushed her face down and I put my face
in front of it and I growl and granted
it doesn't matter how small a doug has
that motherfucker bites.
My friend
had a fucking,
a miniature pincher and this
motherfucker beat the shit out of me.
Once we were watching tv,
I was just sitting there and the thing
snuck up behind me and just jacked me in
the back.
Oh yeah.
Out of nowhere.
It was a creepy dark when on the couch
and just fucking fucking.
Oh,
it was a mean little dog.
I don't know what happened to the little
and development.
You motherfucker.
You nailed it and right away.
But I was like,
dude,
you got to lock your dog up man.
Your dog's a biter.
Punctured skin on my back.
Yeah,
I actually,
it's funny you bring that up.
The reason my son's in taekwondo,
he used to bite other kids when he was
like three.
And we're like,
what the fuck are we going to do when
someone is at taekwondo?
It'll teach them discipline piece and
I'll tell you,
man,
it's six months.
He just stopped and he's like this
well-disciplined kid.
But um,
no,
but it's all,
it's all on me.
This thing with my son.
I know that it's a psychological thing
and it's just.
But I'm,
I'd be embarrassed to think that and I
say it out loud and I do talk about it
onstage because to me that's what stand
up is,
what's the thing I'm most embarrassed
about in my life right now at a deep
level.
And it's like I've,
I've a very oedipal feeling right now,
which is a real thing that dads go
through with sons is you start to my
dad.
I felt that my dad,
but yeah.
But he's a kid
fairly might be a struggle.
Yeah.
And that was start taking Jujitsu now.
Keep him away.
And you start lifting.
Now I believe me,
I see only good things for us in our
future.
It's just a,
it's a weird emotion.
I feel,
you know,
my friend Rick has two kids that are 20
and 18 now and he's like to get both be.
He has this relationship with them.
It's good.
Used to go
period in their late teens when they
fucking hated you and I don't think they
do as much.
I think parents are better now and I
think there's obviously that pull away
part where they have to find themselves
among their friends more than their
family,
but it's not that violent.
I hate you.
I think there was a lot of.
Because I said so when we were growing
up,
what the fuck?
Give me a goddamn x and now I think you
know,
because enough generations get through
that where you say,
I am not going to do that stupid shit
when I have kids.
I'm going to respect my kids
intelligence.
Like I have like long conversations with
my daughter about why it's wrong to do
this and this is what's wrong.
Because when you do that,
I know you feel like it's right,
but you heard other people's feelings
and you should always avoid hurting
other people's feelings.
If you can write right and then we'll
have a long,
long time.
Nobody ever did that with me was because
I fucking said so go to your room and
you know,
that's what,
what we got when we were kids.
They were.
Nobody was educated on how to
psychologically properly evaluate and
how to raise children because their
parents grew up in the fucking
depression when you had it.
My grandfather used to tell stories
about breaking rabbits.
Next,
how you break a rabbit's neck,
put a pot to make rabbit stew.
And I was like,
Jesus,
you hate rabbits.
The fuck was wrong with the world back
then.
And um,
but my grandfather living on a farm,
you know,
as a young boy in Italy.
Yeah.
So she had to do.
There was no getting around that growing
up in a Catholic country like that.
I mean,
there is a,
there's an intense shame that's put upon
you a young age.
You know,
you're,
you're taught at an early age,
you're born into original sin,
Adam and he fucked up.
So you're bad and dirty starting out and
then you get to a sex.
Well,
Jesus came out of an immaculate
conception because any woman that
actually fucks to make a human life is a
whore.
She had to be pure,
like all these images that you may not
even processed,
but they get into your hard drive when
you're young of like,
shame on us.
Shame on this bat.
I,
I was raised with it and it's like the
biggest thing
that's the guilt is the.
The east coast is main curse.
Yeah.
It's one of the things most fucked up
about the east coast is the wave of
Catholic guilt that is just polluted or
the consciousness,
the consciousness of all the different
people there and think about what our
grandparents went through.
Man.
I mean our parents were raised by our
grandparents.
Our grandparents lived in the dark ages.
Essentially.
They lived in an area with no fucking
television.
There was no nothing when they were
children,
there was no nothing there.
There was the written word and you know,
occasionally you would see a photo of
somebody.
Yeah,
know I mean Jesus Christ.
I mean,
imagine what was like growing up
literally at the turn of the century,
1900 mean fuck
you didn't travel.
You had no outside influences,
so whatever you were taught,
whether it's by the church or by your
parents that were living in fear,
that was your whole reality.
You had nothing to balance that out so
you,
you bought it even more so than maybe I
was affected by a Catholic upbringing
back then.
There was no separation between what you
were living and anything outside in the
world
and my grandparents.
I don't know what generation you are all
came over from Ireland.
My grandparents.
Yeah,
mine as well.
Mine.
My grandfather came over from Ireland on
my father's side.
My grandmother on my father's side came
over from Italy and both my grandparents
on my mother's side came over from
Italy,
so everybody took a fucking crazy chance
and jumped in a boat when across the
ocean.
So they were not the nuttiest fuckers
effort.
You didn't even know what stories people
told you.
Stories.
You have to see a picture of what New
York City looks like.
They took a fucking chance like animals,
like
I was thinking about that.
The second you step off the boat,
maybe you got a piece of paper with an
address somewhere in the city.
You've never fucking.
You've never found your way in a foreign
place in your life.
You grew up in one town that you never
left.
Now you're surfing Manhattan trying to
find Second Avenue East.
Crazy and you.
If you've never seen the gangs of New
York,
most people don't know what Manhattan
used to be.
You just kind of assume somehow that it
was always this city at the big
buildings.
No,
it was craziness.
Who was a nutty village.
It was really feudalism gangs of New
York.
It was.
That was really what it was like back
then and it's.
It's an amazing thing to watch.
It sort of puts the whole idea of
settling this country into perspective
because most people can't really wrap
their heads around how quickly the
United States has developed the idea
that 17,
76 it was formed that that's nothing.
That is like nothing.
There was nothing here.
A few houses.
If you fucking log houses here and there
and then all of a sudden in a couple of
hundred years,
wash everything.
Manhattan,
fucking Atlanta,
Chicago fucking roads all the way across
this bitch back and forth.
Covered in.
Yeah.
Horace flying over freaking me out right
now.
The fact that that happens over looking
at your eyes,
I was like,
Holy Shit.
One hundred years,
200 years.
It went from that to 1776 to 1976,
200 years
and then you think about,
and this is my always my thing,
people,
they'll,
well,
black people need to get over it.
There were slaves too to fucking
generations ago.
That's a short period of time to expect
an entire culture of people to recover
from a really fuck.
You talk about Catholicism being fucked
up two generations ago.
How about your mother?
Your grandmother was getting raped and
your,
your father and mother were split up.
Your aunts and uncles were splitter.
I mean that.
That's a lie and the grant.
Granted I'm not like A.
I think affirmative action was a
failure.
I think that we're grappling with how to
try to equalize society for all people.
I don't know the answer,
but I do know that it did.
We got to look at is our problem.
It's not their problem.
I think it has to do with poverty in
general.
I think we have to address poverty from
the standpoint of children's being
children,
being raised in children's,
children's,
being raised in a bad community.
I think children being raised in poverty
and neglect is always the big issue
because if you're,
if you don't do something about those
kids,
now you are just essentially you're
going to give them no choice but to
become criminals themselves.
If they're being raised in the
environment,
the imitate their atmosphere,
everything around them is bad.
Everything around them is negative and
neglect and what is happening?
What is.
There's,
there's,
uh,
there's gotta be a way to get to those
kids to get to those kids and help them
see some something where it helps their
parents or some sort of a community
outreach.
But the idea that people at the top say,
why should I give them anything?
Fucking single mom just wants to have
more kids and like,
well don't you?
Isn't there a root cause of that,
that single mom,
but someone's baby at one point,
obviously someone fuck that baby up bad
that it became a grown adult that just
shits out kids for welfare money,
like what are we going to do is get to
them when they're babies.
You got to them when they're babies and
help them help the mother help for the
sake of the humanity as a whole,
as a super organism.
Officially.
That's the thing.
Service is very often I find that there
is a short sightedness if they're the.
They're the party of economic restraint
and responsibility.
I think that you're creating a bigger
deficit and you're creating a more
fragile economy when you have people
that are uneducated,
that grew up,
like you said,
in an atmosphere where they were abused
and they don't have the tools and
they're role models were shit.
If you allow that to happen,
it's a drain selfishly on your economy.
Yes.
Absolute fucking Luli and on your
safety,
your economy and your safety,
investing in the of inner cities and
building the bad neighborhoods and
turning them into better neighborhoods
and giving people a chance and hope and
giving them a possibility of positively
contributing to society.
So instead of being a burden there,
there's something
anybody wants.
Yes,
root of happiness.
They,
again,
going back to these studies is the most
that you can boil it down to.
And there's this guy that wrote a book
called happiness.
He was a,
he teaches a class at Harvard.
It's the most attended class in the
history of Harvard University and he's a
guy that's taken every type of thought
going back to fucking Confucius and
Jesus and young and then modern
psychiatry and basically just studied it
for a decade and come up with basically
happiness is pursuing something that you
care about and feeling vital.
That's it.
Not Welfare.
Nobody wants to fucking welfare.
Check to re to be a single mom.
People want to be involved.
They want to feel that they,
uh,
they are making an imprint on the earth.
Yeah.
So some some sort of a community
outreach with me and then you know,
you've got to have things that help
people get off drugs just for a fact.
There's going to be people that are
fucked up and they're not going to be
able to make positive decisions because
they're on drugs and if that's your
environment,
if that's your community events,
your neighborhood,
it's within your best interest to clean
these people up.
Yeah.
It's when the war on drugs now heading
off the off the need to do drugs is
what?
What does that treat treatment?
Not incarcerated.
Yeah.
Not and not judging people and the more
things are illegal,
the more people are going to do those
illegal things.
It's always been the case and at least
if you had legality,
you could.
First of all,
it should always be a social pariah and
you should boycott any fucking company
that would profit off the sale of those
drugs.
They should be you,
the drugs,
any drugs that you sell the fuck people
up.
The negative stigma should be the
punishment enough.
You should be disassociated by society
if you choose to sell and something
that's going to cause people to fuck up
their lives.
And we all know that there's drugs that
do that.
And anybody who's selling math is a
piece of shit.
It's 2012.
We've got info,
but there's always going to be a new
hillbilly.
Cocaine is always going to be a fucking
a meal.
Ammonia mixed with this.
That gets you high.
So to me it's about how do we cut out
the abuse?
How do we cut out the loneliness,
the uselessness that creates a need for
drug use or alcohol?
Alcohol is the fucking,
that's the unsung hero of failure.
You know,
it's,
it's worse than drugs and yet it's on in
the superbowl and it's legal.
And uh,
you know,
to me,
I don't want to go down that road
because that's a whole other.
Well,
that's awesome.
When you changed as a person when we
were young,
you got much more serious about your
career as well.
When you quit drinking,
you know,
you,
you went,
you were the first guy that I knew that
uh,
you,
you handled it great because you didn't,
you didn't waver at all.
You're like,
look,
I can't drink.
I drink.
I get fucked up.
I can't handle it,
period.
I don't want to be a loser.
I'm done.
And you did that when you were like 20,
22.
No,
I was probably 24 when I did it and it
was,
you know,
I had started drinking very young and,
but,
but it was stand up.
I mean I couldn't drive to gigs if I
lost my license and stand.
It was the first thing in my life I ever
felt like I might be good at what I was
like,
I'm not going to lose.
This has been my dream since I was a kid
to be a standup.
So you're not,
you know,
you're not a stranger when it comes to
the polls of addiction and the idea that
it could ruin your life and think,
what if you didn't have stand up?
What if you know you were in a pit of
despair with a shit job and no future
aspirations or hopes you know nothing on
the landscape.
Fuck man,
you need an opportunity.
It's got to be a compelling option
because getting high feels fucking
great.
Nobody can deny that and if you don't
feel great and you can feel great,
that's what you're going to do.
And the only thing that feels better is
feeling like people are expecting you to
produce something and you do it and you
feel good.
Well,
especially as an artist,
I mean,
and I hate that word,
you know,
I'm an artist,
but,
but putting out something that you
create,
that people enjoy,
they love it.
You know,
people like podcasts,
like this,
one of your podcasts,
people,
people love the fact that they can get
some enjoyment out of this.
Like when I go to,
um,
I,
I'm the only podcast I really subscribe
to other than a few of my friends still
from desk squad and stuff is a
psychedelic salon.
My favorite podcast,
it's like this guy,
I think his name is Lorenzo.
Lorenzo is the guy who runs it and he,
um,
he puts all these really,
really interesting lectures like Timothy
Leary,
lecturers and Robert Anton Wilson and
Terence Mckenna,
and uh,
you know,
every week there's some new really cool
fucking interesting lecture by some
really educated,
trippy people,
you know,
it's,
it's really awesome.
And when I look at my Ipod,
when I sync my ipod on like,
oh,
keep looking,
you get excited,
you know,
it's like now I know what I'm in,
I'm in my car.
It syncs up with my car.
So I'm driving around,
I'm listening to it and it's a,
I love that.
That's a treat that you can get for
free.
And they've been pretty good feeling to
think that people feel like that when
they see your podcast going down.
And for Brian and I,
it's a particularly satisfying because
we didn't have any aspirations at all.
We just,
we started it off.
You could see the first one's still
available and ustream was with a laptop
is terrible.
It's unwatchable,
right?
Yeah.
It's just because we,
w,
W,
we weren't really paying attention to
it.
As people listening,
we're,
we're more like,
hey,
they're just watching us.
We'll just hang out in the chat room or
something like that.
Paying 30 bitches,
what's going on?
And like read someone's tweets.
Yeah,
dude,
yeah,
we'll come into
New York.
I remember listening to an early one and
gone.
There was just a 32nd pause like you
guys didn't the podcast.
I said I gotta take a shit.
So Brian,
you talked to them.
Surprise,
like,
so everybody do like cats,
like shit moving around and no one's
going to be like,
oh,
I kinda,
this is Kinda cool.
This is just a hang out.
It's the
real evolution of the podcast is
available for everybody to say.
So we,
we,
uh,
I,
I always knew that I always wanted to do
a radio show,
but I always knew that I would never be
able to do a radio show.
Like no one would ever hire me to do a
radio show.
And I thought maybe when satellite radio
came along I was,
I became pals.
Like right when Santa Radio launch.
I became pals with opie and Anthony and
then always like,
you know,
hey,
we have a channel,
you know,
we'd always love to put you on the
channel,
but nothing ever really happened out of
it.
And there was some talks and nothing
ever took pace.
But then once I started doing a podcast
I was like,
oh,
this is like,
this is way easier.
This is.
And now I've got all these people coming
on,
like all these interesting people and
all these like,
uh,
like uh,
like bands like we to be real from
Cypress Hill.
Yesterday,
dude,
we've had everlast when the house of
Payne,
he's done it before and his band honey
honey is on next week.
And then Sam Harris,
the,
the neuroscientist who's the atheist,
a author and lecturer.
He's coming,
he's fucking brilliant.
I'm so excited about him coming on.
But it's like we've been able to turn it
from,
you know,
what he was supposed to be,
it was just us fucking around to what I
really should have probably been doing
in the first place.
I'm sorry,
know what is it?
It's Kinda like when you,
when you were talking about before with
like the office,
the fact that or the man show the fact
that you're stepping into a preconceived
creative paradigm and trying to fill it
up is a failure to start with a podcast
that aspires to nothing.
And then organically it builds itself
and it knows what it is.
It's got a foundation based in who you
really are as opposed to like,
you know,
um,
even as a comedian and he's starting
out,
you go through so many different masks,
you think I'm going to be the,
like I was going to be the clever guy or
you know,
I'm going to be a political comic or I'm
going to use props.
Yeah,
go do it.
Go do it until it doesn't work and it
keeps shedding and then eventually
you're going to be the comic you're
meant to be.
And I think with the podcast,
it's the same thing.
You kind of just,
you explore and you start to feel what
feels right and um,
and hopefully not respond so much to
like,
well,
people love this.
I try to avoid that.
Yeah,
I think,
you know,
people love what you love and if you
pursue,
if you pursue what you love,
then people connected that and they can
appreciate that.
I can appreciate that.
You know,
even if something that I'm not really
into what I love is someone else being
into something.
I love seeing people's passion and
honesty and what you get from a podcast
you don't get from anything else is
there's no restrictions on time.
We don't have to cut to a commercial
there.
The thoughts never have to be
interrupted.
I mean we didn't decide how long we're
going.
We've been on for like two hours and 40
minutes or something like that.
What's.
Yeah,
yeah,
let's do it all the time.
Yeah.
We do that all the time and they just go
on and take a 15 second pause.
This.
You don't get an opportunity to have a,
those kinds of conversations in,
in the,
in,
in.
Especially with someone that's in the
public eye or something that's a comic.
No one gets a chance to really get to
know you like they do in this form or
like they do on your podcast where
you're constantly communicating with
them when they've heard you communicate
for 100 hours,
they fucking know.
Yeah.
You can only hide so much
and you know,
what's amazing is every podcast,
no matter how long I end up hanging out
with the guests for another 45 minutes
afterwards and you're like,
but I want to leave.
But you could have just kept going.
Yeah.
And well,
I do.
I do to a point.
I always feel like a lot of times
because I do the serious show first,
I've already given me an hour and then I
usually shoot a video with them.
I do this thing called talk your way out
of it where I give people and on I'll do
it to you right now.
I'm going to give you an uncomfortable
situation and in a split second,
you're going to have to talk your way
out of it as if you're talking to the
person.
Okay?
All right.
Um,
are you go to the doctor's office and
uh,
he's gonna,
he's gonna check you out.
So,
um,
he bends you over the table and then you
go.
He says,
oh,
I forgot the rubber gloves.
He walks out.
You notice that the medicine cabinets
open,
you reach and you find a bottle of
Vicodin.
You see it as he's coming in,
he's going to bust you.
You take it,
you stick it up your ass to hide it.
The doctors spreads your cheeks.
He wants to look at you.
Look at your colon because his finger
and he pulls out the bottle of Igon and
talk your way out.
Oh,
that's where that was the word by words.
It's all,
you're in the clear,
oh,
that's where it is.
Thanking them thinking maybe.
But usually it takes like two minutes.
People talk around it.
They described you average five words.
Just go right for C'mon man.
You can't,
you're already busted guy.
Found a bottle up your ass.
You're a freak.
I did that.
I did that too.
Not that particular one.
I thought of [inaudible].
My last show was with Natasha and I did
that to her,
but it was in her pussy and she had her
feet in the stirrups and she goes,
oh,
I was just tightening that for you.
Yeah.
But,
um,
yeah.
So,
um,
fuck.
This is great.
I just forgot we were talking about it
doesn't matter.
Oh yeah.
Those touches closer.
You're talking about and push you
through to be fucking with you son.
Jesus.
That's what it is.
That image,
the image of her in her underwear.
What's your image right now?
When you jerk off?
What's your scenario?
That works?
Um,
it's variable changes go through
streaks.
One particular thing or another.
I stay.
I tried to stay away from porn when I
first had kids just because of the idea
of the daughter that would eventually
become someone that's someone's baby,
but you know,
I can't fix it.
It is what?
It is.
A Dick.
Yeah.
Who Do you want?
What's your,
what you're saying?
I don't have.
You don't go to like categories and
picked just what's crazy.
It looks hot.
Whatever's nuts.
Yeah.
I used to have like types,
but I'm going to have types in your,
you never know,
just click around with it now.
I can't,
I can't watch Asian porn anymore.
I watch too much of it.
And then I started to feel like when I
saw Asian women,
you know,
in the,
uh,
real world,
I started to feel weird like,
like I want to apologize for being off
someone on a steady diet of Asians,
Asian,
cause I didn't get any when I was young
and I got before I,
you know,
I
used to date a lot of black women and I
dated a couple of Tina women and I never
dated an Asian women and I find them
just absolutely.
They're so beautiful and they're
their feet,
if such cute little feet,
you would have loved Japan.
Japan.
They're so friendly.
So friendly.
Yeah.
Brian and I were just talking about the
other day when we got back,
we were just there together for the UFC.
Now are you married,
Brian?
So you get to experience a girlfriend?
I have a girlfriend.
Yeah.
Good,
good.
Tell,
um,
the,
the beauty of the culture is the
politeness and the women are so polite
as well.
Men are simple.
Everyone's so polite in restaurants and
bars.
Everywhere you go,
everyone,
like when people run into people on the
street,
like everyone's just like,
there's there.
They're so polite.
It's a completely different culture than
ours.
Really.
Fascinating.
It almost literally truly is like an
alien world.
Like you land in a world where
everybody's just polite.
The language is totally different.
The people all like,
you know,
they look Japanese,
the universally look Japanese,
Japanese do.
It's amazing.
So you're in this new place where
everyone behaves super polite,
very orderly.
Like when they had the tsunamis and they
were giving out aid,
people just waited patiently,
politely disciplined,
you know,
I mean,
he,
the driver was really interesting.
We had a really cool driver and he spoke
very good English two.
And one of the things he said was about
the,
the deal,
the deal with Radiation Fukushima,
that a lot of people are sick and the
government lies about it.
And he was like,
well,
the problem is that we trust the
government,
the God we don't.
They don't,
they're not in the rising up and
questioning the government.
People are into the trust.
The government,
the government has their best interest
and then they keep their eyes on their
own business and they do what they have
to do.
So there's not a lot of like,
this mother fucker go.
We tell him to take this motherfucker
down.
There's none of that.
They're not there.
It's politeness and not,
not subservient.
See.
But knowing your place,
discipline,
respect,
you know,
you never tried a community.
You don't,
don't try to do better than your boss.
You don't try to do better in your box.
Yeah.
Callan was telling me that when you.
There's etiquette as far as businessmen
and like say if your boss orders a
certain type of Scotch,
like a very expensive old scotch,
you don't order that.
You order newer,
cheaper scotch and you order.
You don't order what he ordered.
Yeah.
And a bow is based on that.
Also.
Do you bow lower to somebody who's
superior?
Good question.
Yeah.
The lower you are,
the lower your bmi under that person,
so like that's why you can get in a
fight with somebody if they think that
they are lower than you and that's where
it's like back and forth,
rams on.
You're sucking your own Dick.
He knows what's up guys.
You know you're losing the bowel
contents when you sucking.
Don't pee pee or something,
you know you're underneath somebody when
you're looking at the guy behind you.
Do you remember when one of the funniest
things about doing the road was like
working with black comics because if
black comics were supposed to be the
Middle Act,
they always had heard from the book or
that there was supposed to be the
headliner.
If there was two other black acts,
there will always go up first I believe,
and I got another gig because they all
wanted to do like some of the same
references.
Like with road hacks,
there's like,
like black road hacks had so many stock
jokes.
There was so much.
Like I haven't seen this many white
people since my trial
at what am I,
what am I the only chocolate chip and a
cookie tonight times.
Have you heard that?
Or the fame or the fat guy who takes the
mic stand moves and let me get that out
of the way so you can see me.
Applause.
Laughter.
That was a thing about Boston was that
Boston did not tolerate hacks.
We were so lucky that we came up in a in
a time where that shit was ridiculed
when we would go on the road and we
would work with
you guys.
Fucking look at what you fucking act.
Yep.
Look what you're.
And then when you go to New York,
when your boss to comic and you go down
in New York,
all of a sudden they're like,
fuck man,
you're good.
It's like,
yeah,
because we had to be different,
you know,
and you had to not be happy,
but the further you travel from Boston,
the more,
like you said,
use your bit.
Maybe do the guy comes in late.
What do you say when the guy comes in
late?
Ya.
Oh,
I don't remember.
Can I get you anything?
Like a fucking clock?
Yeah.
Every time.
And it's applause break every.
You had like those savers and you
wouldn't dare do that Shit in Boston,
but if you were up in Maine race to who
can do that first?
Hey,
I don't come to your job.
Slap the digs out of your mouth.
That was a
jim in your pocket.
There was a lot of tools that we had
like especially as young scrubs.
It's almost like what you had was a
scaffolding that allowed you to put
together your little comedy
really didn't have the structure to do
it on its own on its own.
It wouldn't hold up.
So you had it.
So I'm saying the guys in the background
going,
I've fucked your mother and I'm like,
Dad,
no one cares.
And the guys and the other comics in the
back,
crossing it off.
That one.
Napa.
Do you remember those normal?
A full gigs js and Pittsfield and Oh my
God.
It was like I'd never been to western
Massachusetts and you would just get on
the mass pike and he'd get off some
exit.
Just a number with woods around it and
then you drive for another 45 minutes.
Then you get to a normal phone,
western Massachusetts as a trip.
That's why Umass Boston or Umass amherst
rather.
So beautiful.
That amherst town.
It's amazing.
It's really cool.
Fucking town in the middle of nowhere in
western Massachusetts and there's so
many towns like that where it's like,
what has brought the town together is
essentially
college and stayed.
Yeah.
You go to Madison,
Wisconsin.
Yeah.
Yeah,
exactly.
I think in Nebraska,
boulder,
Colorado,
it was a lot of places like that.
But yeah,
that's why I always think like,
you know,
um,
I really would like to teach at some
point I was thinking back,
cool college town.
Um,
I would like to teach comedy.
I'd like to teach like,
you know,
um,
all aspects of it,
you know,
comic history method.
Yeah.
Essentially in a phd in standup master.
I mean I've written it on sitcoms.
I've written it on late night.
I've written sketches.
I've done stand up for me.
Yeah.
So talk shows or.
Yeah,
I bought a Alan Generous to,
for producing in two for writing and
then I won a,
a,
I want a,
I'm,
what the fuck was it called?
Ace Award for you and Ellen besties.
Oh fuck.
She just called me.
God dammit.
I got to call that bitch back.
No,
no,
we're not IBM.
We're nothing.
Did you ever kiss her on the lips?
I did.
Did you?
Did you ever wonder would it be like to
make love to her?
Yes.
Really just thinking about that.
Like,
that's got to be weird.
Um,
well I think if you put me in an office
with a number of women by the end of the
week,
I will have imagined each of them.
Did you ever see her Mac?
You ever see her?
Put her,
put her girl Mac down.
Last time I talked about this,
I got a call from a lawyer.
Yeah.
Really?
I can't talk.
Wow.
Oh,
did you sign a nondisclosure when you
work there?
Oh,
you shouldn't be talking to me right
now.
She's an awesome person.
Right?
I love her.
Love her to show love everything about
it.
You know,
it's wild.
I saw her on one of those hp,
a young comedian specials.
They plan on hbo now or have you seen
him?
Yeah,
it's fucking great,
isn't it?
It's like I saw her in these balloony
fucking like joy,
but a fuko pants and the shirt and uh,
and the,
and the mullet.
And then he said like,
Jerry Seinfeld,
come on and he's like,
looks like he's fucking 11 years old.
I love watching.
No,
that's a good one,
man.
I just wonder what ever happened to the
gun?
Rick Ducommun.
Oh God,
yeah.
Rick Ducommun was fucking on him.
Yeah.
He had some good shit.
Yeah,
he was.
It was always angry at everything,
but it was a different kind of anger.
He was like,
he leaves the microphone in the stand.
I remember that because like,
all my guys like my favorite comics,
like prior kinison and George Carlin,
they always carried the microphone,
but he would leave in the stand.
I was like,
wow,
she's angry with it in a stand.
This is a new approach.
Yeah.
He was a funny guy,
man.
I always wondered like,
there's always a few guys,
like they were really funny at one point
in time.
Then you're like,
where's that guy
will happen,
but you know,
as cool as like Dana Gould,
to me it was like that when he was
young,
I was like,
fuck,
there's nobody funnier than this guy.
And then he went off to write for the
simpsons and you know,
cat casual friends with.
I'm much better friends with him now,
didn't see him for years,
and then all of a sudden he came back
with a vengeance and now he's like
phenomenal again,
but in a totally different way.
I watched him,
one of his first sets back,
he still had it,
but it was weird watching the guy put
together a new app and they lacked and
though he clearly knew how to do
standup,
but it was like you could see him doing
it going like,
wow,
this is.
It was really kind of interesting.
Yeah.
Well,
it's like with Chris rock every
time,
man,
when he stuck.
Here's the thing about Chris Rock,
you got like Dave Chappelle who I think
came out of the womb,
grabbed the mic and was funny,
and then you got Chris Rock who's a guy
when,
I don't know if you've seen him when he
starts out,
it's fucking painful.
He was
him getting ideas and not knowing where
they're going and trudge it out on stage
and not have it work at all.
No,
I mean he,
he's a guy who I think is obviously
extremely funny,
but at the same time I think he's
cerebral funny where he,
he thinks about it,
he writes it,
he rewrites it,
he works hard and then he comes up with
an hour like his is bigger and blacker
is it?
Was that what it's called?
I mean,
I'd put it against any hour of stand up
ever,
but,
but the way people get there is a,
you know,
it's,
it's fucking different for everybody and
uh,
you know,
I think seeing somebody start to finish
that,
that to me is a great tv show.
I'd like to see something on comedy
central where you watch,
you know,
put the cameras on four or five comics
for the remodel and watch them develop,
you know,
interesting comic,
different styles and watch them right
home,
rewrite
different show.
Dude,
you should pitch that.
You know,
the.
The thing is though that very few guys
actually put together an act like Louis
does every year.
Like to have people do it like that,
but if you force comics to do it for a
show that's good.
At the end of it,
you do a special and the end of it,
they all do a half an hour.
It's an hour and a half specially if
fall.
Three comics over the course of a year
and over that or six months,
say six months for 30 minutes of
material.
That's like,
that's plenty of time.
That's fair.
Yeah.
You know what really,
you could probably do it in three
months.
I think you got to do three because
that'd be tough.
I get it right.
Well,
unless you could come,
I mean you could pace it out where you
come to them like once every couple
weeks or something to people.
Yeah.
And I wonder if there's a three.
You follow three,
but you fall,
you really follow six and use the best
three,
right?
Yeah.
And I think there's a awesome.
Maybe you front load it with like they
each have to get topics,
a sign if you want to make kind of a
reality show that paid off with,
you know,
this new 15 minutes.
But you know,
just to keep it honest,
they have to start.
I don't know if they all start with the
same topics or they draw from a hat for
topics.
Something to give it like,
yeah,
some like real last comic standing shit
because you know what I didn't like
about last comic standing when they
forced those guys to start auditioning
in front of two judges,
do their act like what the fuck is that?
That's not even stand up.
If you really want to watch them do
standup,
go watch them do fucking stand.
You're making a guide.
Tell jokes to you.
Give him some dignity.
Yeah.
And you're trying to do this whole,
uh,
the,
what's his name from um,
the English,
the English guy,
star search,
Simon,
Simon.
Callow bullshit.
They're like trying to be like,
please enough.
That joke is never going to work.
You know,
they're,
they're doing this like harsh judgment
thing because there's a lot.
That's what a lot of people like,
you know,
I don't,
I don't think that's the way to.
So I think the way to a standup show
is not in front of a live audience like
that.
It's in front of a bunch of live on the
fall guy around.
Yeah.
Have a reality show where you've fallen
standups,
where they're putting together a
special.
And then at the end of the whole thing,
they actually do their special monster
live event being at a,
at a good size theater.
Only problem though is then the people
are going to know the material.
So really the best way to do it because
you're going to coordinate in advanced.
Yeah.
You,
you bet.
You bank the whole thing and then you
roll it out later.
Yeah,
you couldn't do it live,
but you could,
but you could do it that way.
When you watch a live audience respond
to that material and you see how that
guys developed it and you'd really
appreciate it as a,
as a person who enjoys the craft of
comedy,
you know,
sucks.
Write it up.
Let's write it out.
I'm going to pitch it,
what we call it.
Um,
common upcoming can comma,
Q,
how?
Kent area.
Um,
I think we call it a from scratch comic
from scratch,
something like that.
I like that.
I like that because that's essentially
what it is.
And then he picked.
People have really different styles.
Comedy from scratch.
That's perfect.
You nailed it.
That's it.
That's the name you get.
I like,
maybe you get the same five topics.
You're gonna do 15 minutes on five
topics.
Then you get a guy who's a storyteller.
You get a guy who's a setup punchline
guy.
You get.
Yeah,
but you were.
We're limiting ourselves that we give
them topics.
If you just let the guy explore,
then you get to see where he's coming up
with his material,
but you don't know if he didn't already
write it.
I want to make sure they're.
They're not pulling some old shit out.
That's true.
Plus it'd be all come jokes.
Well,
you know what?
We know when you disqualify them from
the show,
if they do say,
listen man,
you can't lie about this.
If we find out you're lying about this,
you're fucked.
We want,
you know,
we want all new material.
I still feel like it needs a starting
point.
It needs like a crisp,
like,
okay,
how about maybe,
how about this?
Maybe there's,
there's three comics,
right?
We want them to have five new topics.
Each one has five new top,
but assign them five topics that may
come up with material,
but they have like a fucking big wheel
and they have to reach in and pull the
topics out.
Yeah,
that's good.
Yeah.
Like we spin the wheel and your reach
in,
what's your first topic?
Marriage Shit.
Yeah.
And then there's also the pitfalls of
hackery,
like how do you avoid,
you know,
like this subject's been dumped your,
you have to do a joke about women's
tampons.
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
You know that Jesus Christ do a joke
about buying women's tampons.
Is that what you're going to do?
A price check price check tampons.
Aisle five.
I mean,
is that,
how can you avoid the.
Yeah.
Well let's play it right now.
I'll give you a topic.
You do a joke.
You've given me a topic.
We'll play three rounds.
All right.
I'm going to start.
Um,
and they.
And they should be hackey premise just
to prove that you don't have to do it.
I'm kittens.
I fucked him.
Oh,
come came.
big fat.
Fucking ace.
Yeah.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm midlife crisis cars.
If you buy a prius you might as well
just put a white flag and your balls
hanging from the antenna because it's
over.
Greg actually bought a prius because we
were having a conversation before he
goes,
I go,
please tell me this is your Prius.
He goes,
yes.
It no idea what Venice mobile living in
Venice and the worst thing is is I still
fucking.
I still have driving rage and I cut
people off and the weird thing is
there's a button on your dashboard on
the new Prius where it takes all the
electrical shit out and it's just a fast
light little Toyota and you go really
fast and you get no gas mileage and
that's how I drive all the time.
They did a thing on top gear where they
had a prius and an m three and they sent
them around a race track and the
[inaudible] actually ate less gas than
the Prius did when it was driving around
meant for around town.
That's where you save the gas.
Now when I'm dropping,
go my fucking Florence,
but what he wanted with Greg really
wanted was a one of those spiffy new
dodge challenger was awesome.
The hammies.
Those cars are awesome.
They sound good.
They fucking look great.
That shape is satisfying.
I found one and I was looking at it.
It was a year old.
I got it down to Carmax and I was going
to get a flight fucking 24,000
loaded via and then my wife and kids
were gone.
Daddy,
the environment,
you've got to get a prius kind of pushes
you raise right now.
And I just,
uh,
I,
I cave me mom filled with conflict
minerals.
Okay.
Prius's have lithium ion batteries to
getting those from fucking little kids
picking up minerals from Congo.
It's terrible.
Yeah,
it's,
there's nothing,
there's nothing good about the way they
construct those fucking things now.
Now the only ideas that using less gas
while you actually use it.
Yeah.
And what do you do with the batteries
when it's done?
It's a,
I made it.
I made a mistake.
I made a pretty big mistake.
Motherfuckers kp from a challenger,
that's a man's car.
I know you can appreciate when you hit
that gas and hit the rumble of the Va,
you feel it.
It's a car.
It's a man's car to man's car.
And you know,
when I pull up to a red light,
I'm next to a woman,
I'm married and whatever,
but I need to be able to look her in the
eye.
And with the Prius,
your eyes go straight ahead and you just
keep straight ahead.
Useless.
This girl fucking popped the Zit on the
side of her face in front of my
direction in front of me while I was at
a red light.
You're off the menu,
she's looking at a Prius,
driving a little bit in front of you.
The blood comes out,
keep squeezing until the blood squirts.
There's certain things you don't want to
ever see a girl do.
If you're gonna fuck her.
A zit is one of them.
Take a shit.
It's another.
You don't.
Oh no shit around the butthole.
Go Watch them.
Shit.
I mean,
not at this point in time,
you know?
Yeah.
But you know,
when you're a young man,
I have a friend who,
uh,
was in love with this chick.
And he came over her house and he lifted
up the toilet bowl,
take leak.
There was a floater and he couldn't fuck
her.
He was like,
it was done.
It was over.
It was like 20.
When you're 40,
you just flush it for then you hope she
wiped 20.
She could take a shit.
I mean,
nothing would stop me.
Shit on your balls.
Actually,
that would be a.
Now that now we're going to find that
site.
You.
Have you ever dated a girl that was into
like weird shit,
like she wanted you to piss on or
anything crazy?
It was a girl that used to like me to
choke her and slap her.
Oh,
I've had a lot of that in my car because
she was a waitress at a club in Boston.
I never would do the slapping thing,
but I've choked the fuck out of some
jokes from behind or are from all kinds
of ways.
I had one girl that wanted to wrestle
before we fucked,
would always wrestle,
like push me.
She would push me.
I'd come over her house and she drew
what?
I go,
And she looks I'm going to fucking
wrestle.
Oh are you serious?
Like,
what are you talking about?
And she pushed me.
She goes,
you know,
I'm fucking.
I'm like,
okay,
what is going on here?
Like what are you doing?
And she should go when he's scared,
he's scared getting beaten by a girl and
then we'd be in this like little wrist
fight thing.
Was she grabbing my wrists and shit?
Then I'd have to manhandle her and
that's what she wanted.
She wanted to just get dominated.
Yeah,
yeah,
I could see that.
Yeah,
got crazy.
she would almost what it essentially was
what she wanted to.
She wanted to get raped by somebody that
she wanted to fuck her.
That's what she wanted to do.
That was her thing,
but it's,
I'll go.
This is a very confusing,
you know,
we were talk about when they shut
fucking raped me,
like she was crazy and I go,
listen,
I don't,
I don't want to rape you.
Okay.
If you want me to fuck you as if I raped
you,
that we can do.
Okay.
But I want to know when you're fighting
me off that you want me to do this.
Like,
this is confusing as fuck and I don't
want to develop any taste for this.
Yeah,
I know.
That's just it.
Because you've been socialized to not
rape.
She's unsocialized in you and that's.
That doesn't make.
May Not be limited to her pool.
And it,
by the way,
took a while to get this out of her.
When we first started dating,
she was like super normal.
Like it came.
It was,
it was like,
it took some time.
We got to like what she really liked.
It was really weird.
It's like as she got a little bit more
comfortable with me,
she would like want to arm wrestle me or
something and it was real weird and over
the course of a couple of months,
that next thing pretty quickly I was
just fucking thrown around.
Dude was ridiculous.
I would like hoist her up in the air and
like toss her through the air and shit
the best is you meet a guy later and
you're like,
oh you stay Jennifer.
I was dating Jennifer and just look at.
I'm like,
yeah,
you just shake your head and walk away.
It wasn't Jennifer just,
Oh,
I didn't mean to say Jennifer.
She was a nice girl.
Now she was great,
but I had a girl.
I did a.
When I was at the neighborhood
playhouse,
we had a scene from Farrah Fawcett did
this movie,
I forget what it was called,
but she gets raped.
Oh,
the burning.
Yes,
exactly.
Yes.
So we're doing the rape scene from that
and I'm like,
we get a that and I'm like fuck.
And this girl is like not a great face
but giant rag,
good body.
And so we have to rehearse it and so we
go to,
you get to go to the workspace and
there's a combination lock and we go in
and it's just us and we're practicing
the rape scene where I literally knock
her down,
get on top of her,
rip her blouse on Jesus and I'm a kind
of dry humping her while she screams.
So we start to rehearse it in.
The reason why we have to go to the
studio alone is we try to do it in class
and he was like,
this is completely not believable.
You guys are so aware and you're so
inhibited,
you need to let this scene out together,
come do it.
So we go to the studio and uh,
and I get on top of her and I ripped her
shirt.
She said,
you know what,
I brought an extra shirt.
You can just just rip it and I rip it
giant rack and I start and I'm and I'm
dry humping and we're supposed to be
doing the lines and,
and we just start like dry humping,
dry humping and I keep and I was so
embarrassed that I kept stopping.
I raging art on and I'm rubbing it
against you could redo the scene and she
was totally into it and I was totally,
totally sexually oh,
it was such a turnout.
It was both totally into it and she was
dating a guy in the class so I wasn't
going to go over that line,
but I had to get in the head as an actor
of being a rapist and I just couldn't do
it.
I couldn't give over to really feeling
what it would feel it because to really
tap into what it would feel like to rape
somebody and want to.
I guess it would require me shedding so
many constraints.
Do you know what I mean?
Like I don't know how you could really
portray a rapist.
I felt like apologizing the whole time
that I was doing it.
Yeah.
That's a weird to put your mind into
that place and then to.
To trust it to not actually.
Yes,
that's what it was.
I didn't know when the breaks we're
going to go on if I let that.
I was afraid that if I let it out I
couldn't stop because it's an every man.
Every man has some chimpanzee inside of
them and chimps are just raping each
other left and right.
Hey,
love it.
That's what they do.
They love to write,
so you get some pussy.
You gotta take it.
Well,
and,
and in,
in America,
I think we've gotten away from that and
you know,
one of the things you were talking about
when we were playing pool that I totally
agree with is that people aren't afraid
of getting punched in the face anymore.
And that's a problem.
That's a problem.
You know,
we've,
we've lost biologically and your act,
I know it's been,
uh,
you,
you play a lot with the idea of the
animal kingdom and how as humans we have
to stop denying the connection.
Basically.
We're a species and,
and we developed as a species by getting
punched in the face and being killed for
doing this action.
And so the other people survived and
they didn't do that action and that's
what shaped us.
And it's also like when I see a guy on
it,
like there was a guy in his convertible
the other day and he was talking on his
Bluetooth phone and I forget what he was
saying,
but just being allowed for self-involved
Douche who didn't look around and
everyone could hear him.
And I just thought I want to punch this
guy in the face.
You know when I should and I should
because I'm doing society a disservice
by not punching him in the face and if
we.
What is it about someone that's talking
loud with a convertible and a bluetooth?
It's so offensive
to me.
We live in a society that is supposed to
be aware of its other members and all
working towards a certain set of beliefs
like I'm respecting each other's space
and not being a flashy car,
so don't.
And it wasn't like he wanted attention
to social bias.
You're not giving me the credit of being
a pedestrian who,
who doesn't want to hear you,
you're,
you're not even looking at me.
You're making me feel like I don't exist
and you're making me feel like whatever
you're talking about is more important
than me.
And I know that sounds weird,
but it's,
it's a subconscious thing where you feel
like you're not validating.
Even the fact that I'm a pedestrian.
Right,
right,
right.
And it's not necessarily right.
You know,
if you,
if you do have your fucking car and you,
you answer a phone call,
you're like,
dude,
I'm A.
I've got my top down right now and I'm
stopped.
Let me put the top on.
I'll call you right back.
Yeah,
right.
I would never talk to somebody in a
restaurant or coffee shop.
Uh,
you know,
there's just things I wouldn't,
you don't talk to someone on the phone.
You mean I go outside.
He really always text when you're at a
dinner or a restaurant.
Only when somebody like goes to the
bathroom or whatever,
you know,
like I don't check texts that often
because I feel like there's like,
I feel like life has a rhythm that we've
lost and if I'm constantly available
then I'm not.
My rhythm is thrown off because it's
something can happen in that text that
changes my thought too.
Oh,
I gotta call that guy back or I get to
do that.
I suddenly become a servant of my
messages coming in,
but I try to space it out every two or
three hours.
I don't think there's anything that
important that I can't ignore.
I'm very addicted to a technological
technological communication,
whether it's twitter or texting or.
It's very hard for me if my phone's in
my pocket,
I it vibrates.
I know I got a text.
I almost have to read it.
Are you a multitasker though?
That's not good.
Especially when you're having a
conversation with someone at a
restaurant.
You really shouldn't be texting people
at a restaurant.
I avoid it whenever possible.
I'm ashamed.
Like I'll excuse myself and go to the
bathroom and then check my emails.
I would never do it at the table.
It's a.
it's an interesting thing because we.
We do have this weird disconnect when
we're right in front of each other,
like this is the ultimate is to be right
in front of a person and communicate
with them.
But meanwhile you're sitting there
exchanging text words with someone who's
nowhere near you while there's a person
right in front of you and they feel less
important now,
unless it's something like fucking super
important and really what is really what
is what is while you're having a
conversation,
you get three calls a year.
They really are like,
you know,
you gotta call back for this thing
that's coming tomorrow or your wife has
taken the kid to the hospital
and I love the fact about the iphone.
If I look at my phone,
I get the message right there.
Didn't even have to read,
so I know.
Help call me right now.
Oh,
okay.
There's something going on.
Yeah,
but what's up bitch?
Oh no,
that one's not important.
Yeah,
no.
Yeah.
I mean,
look,
we used to come home and uh,
there was no answering machine even,
you know what I mean?
People lived.
We got by and I think that like how hard
was it to find people?
It was hard.
You had to stick to a,
we got,
we got to
end this because if it goes over three
hours,
itunes shits on itself and doesn't know
how to handle it.
Didn't seriously go that dude,
we got to do this more often.
That was flat.
Flew.
How do people get your podcast?
I know it's available on Sirius,
on Howard one-on-one.
That's the radio show.
The radio show,
podcast and radio shows different.
The podcast,
but a podcast is fits dog radio.
There's an app called Fitz dog and then
a itunes and my site is [inaudible] dot
com.
And my book,
I've got an audio book,
the one I told you I wrote it as an
audio book of or a version available on
audible.com.
You're right.
It did.
You read it.
I read it and then I had a bunch of
other people read it like it's all
letters that my mother saved my whole
life when I was in trouble.
So I've got like Zach Alfin,
acus and Adam curl.
I got all these famous people reading
the letters as if they're the teachers.
Oh,
that's awesome.
That's cool.
Dear Ms Dot Fitzsimons,
right,
dear.
Miss Fitzsimmons.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
Beautiful.
Could I do all right man?
Um,
and so people know how to get you on
twitter.
It's fits Greg Fitz show on twitter.
That's it at Greg Fitz show.
Thanks for coming.
My pleasure.
We got to do this more often.
Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought
to you by the fleshlight.
Want to thank the flashlight for being
the first sponsor of this.
Proud pod,
we wouldn't even be proud.
What are we?
Fuck we are we just existing.
We look,
we love you.
We just have to do this.
Uh,
thanks to the flashlight in a go to Joe
Rogan.net.
Click on the link and during the code
name Brogan and you get 15 percent off.
Thank you to on a.com,
create alpha brain.
If you're interested in any of this
stuff or just go to o,
n n I t there's ample information.
Any criticisms that we've had about that
information to pass,
it's all been reworked and it's done in
the proper manner as far as scientific
studies there in the middle of doing a
double blind.
Placebo studies had an accredited
university right now.
So this is a real supplement.
I love it.
Uh,
I,
I take it every day.
It's a nootropic.
If you don't know when nootropics are,
I suggest you google it.
New Tropics and O,
o t r o p I c s,
and what it is essentially it's
nutrients for cognitive function and
increases your brain's production of
neurotransmitters.
And it helps you function better how
your brain works smoother.
Um,
it's not going to make you smart if
you're stupid,
but it's interesting stuff.
Google it,
check it out.
Go to [inaudible] dot com,
check out all the different stuff that
we have available and entering the
codename Brogan.
And you will get 10 percent off anything
you buy from now until eternity.
Thank everybody for tuning in.
We appreciate the fuck out of you.
As always,
please come to see us at the Bray Improv
this weekend.
Friday,
Saturday,
and Sunday there'll be me,
Duncan trussell are fear and brian red
bands going to drop in and fucking show
his shit
to right.
Bella.
Saturday.
Saturday is going to get his freak on.
So a good times are coming.
It looks like Atlanta for 20 April 20th
at the Tabernacle.
It looks like that's where I'm going to
be doing my special.
We already sold out the first show and
we're going to add a second show
eventually,
shortly.
Soon.
And that's it.
For more information,
go to Joe Rogan.net.
That is fucking podcast.
Who is over.
I don't have the ending song right now.
Oh,
well,
there's no ending song,
so that's signature.
Anything.
Say,
Greg,
I love this.
I love this fucking podcast.
Fun.
That was fun.
I cannot believe it's three hours.
No,
no,
no.
Seven slash 25.